Hallo Stefan.
Unser Kanzler hat eine Ideologie. Kennste das gut oder schlecht?
Ideologie-Kritiker, sage ich.
Sehr gut. Und ich finde es auch gut, denn es ist, wie soll man sagen, ein Spektakel. Ihr habt ja im Wohlstand für alle die Mashmayer, dieses Mashmayer-Ding da gelesen.
Die Start-up-Gang.
Die Start-up-Gang. Ich hatte davon irgendwo gehört, keine Ahnung. Erst dachte ich, soll ich dich darauf hinweisen? Nee, das wird schon sein Weg finden. Du wirst wahrscheinlich tausend Hinweise bekommen.
Ich habe einige Hinweise bekommen, tatsächlich. Und dachte, als ich den dritten Hinweis bekam, nee, also das mache ich nicht. Dann kam der vierte, fünfte Hinweis. Dann habe ich doch mal reingelesen und dachte, oh Gott, das ist hier so gruselig. Und dann überlegt man, ist es Lebenszeit? Aber andererseits denkt man auch, ja, man hat das hier so in Reinform mal. Also man hat so diese ganze Maschmeier-Ideologie und alles, was da dranhängt, das bekommt man da so mal aufgeschrieben. Und dann war ich auch wieder dankbar, dass Olaf dann auch sagte, nee, das müssen wir machen. Das ist interessant. Und man kann es ja dann auch ein bisschen amüsant vielleicht machen. Aber wenn ich dann... Und das war tatsächlich so, dass ich dann danach den Sandel gelesen habe. Und das ist sehr, sehr heilsam, würde man heute sagen.
Genau, der Sandel. Lass uns direkt reinspringen. Der englische Titel lautet Tyranny of Merit. Ja, viel besser. Ja, finde ich auch. Die Tyrannei des Verdienstes. Damit ist aber nicht der Verdienst gemeint, den man auf dem Konto hat, sondern der Verdienst als Prinzip, als Konzept.
Deutsch vom Ende des Gemeinwohls.
Genau, auf Deutsch vom Ende des Gemeinwohls. Ich finde, auch ein guter Titel, aber trifft nicht so ganz den Punkt. Denn das Gemeinwohl spielt in dem Perifé dann schon eine große Rolle, aber es geht eigentlich nicht so sehr um das Gemeinwohl extern, sondern um den Kopf intern. Wie schon gesagt, dieses zweite Kapitel ist einfach umwerfend und umhauend. Ich habe nicht ganz verstanden, es kam ja 2020 raus, relativ früh. Und trotzdem schlägt das schon so einen großen Bogen um Corona. Kann natürlich auch sein, dass er einfach noch mal bekräftigt wurde. Also ich referiere gleich, wie er das Buch beginnt. Aber ich fand das so passend, als wäre das noch mal die ultimative Bestätigung, dass man ein Buch schreibt und wenn man eigentlich fertig ist damit. Und der Verlag nur noch sagt, so wir würden jetzt auch das Vorwort setzen, willst du noch irgendwas ändern? Und dann sagt man so, ich nehme jetzt noch mal zwei Wochen. Denn es ist gerade Corona und es würde wunderbar passen, es alles noch mal neu zu rahmen.
So wird es auch sein, denn Corona kommt ja sonst in dem Text nicht vor. Aber er rahmt es damit am Anfang.
Genau und er beginnt, Corona traf Amerika, das reichste Land der Welt, unvorbereitet. Und dann das Offensichtliche. Kein Material, keine Tests und ein blöder Präsident. Also sozusagen die Unheilformel, die man sich so nicht wünscht für diesen Moment. Man erkennt wieder, man ist abhängig von China. Aber, und das ist ja dann sein eigentlicher Dreh, wir waren auch moralisch unvorbereitet. Wir hatten eine Parteienkrise, die Parteien kommen miteinander nicht klar, sie kommen mit sich nicht klar, der Präsident kommt mit seiner Partei nicht klar, nichts funktioniert. Wir haben ein krasses Misstrauen in die Medien. Noch mal dann sozusagen in dem Moment, wo eigentlich so ein wir versammeln uns jetzt mal hinter der Tagesschau und dem Kanzler, ja, ist in Amerika so, ne, wir versammeln uns ja mal gar nicht. Also das ist ja erstmal der Anlass jetzt zu sagen, ne, also jetzt wird alles nur noch politisch hochgejässt. Und der einzige Spruch, der damals galt, und wir haben ihn damals auch so kritisiert, wir sitzen alle in einem Boot, stimmt einfach nicht. Es war ein ganz leerer Satz. We are all in this together ist ein ganz falscher Satz. Das einzige Moment an Solidarität, das wir gerade erleben, ist die auf Basis der gemeinsam geteilten Angst. Halten wir Abstand voneinander. Hier rückt niemand zusammen. Hier begründet man nichts Neues, sondern man hat erst mal nur Angst voreinander und verständigt sich zumindest darüber, dass man jetzt Abstand voneinander hält. Also eine Welt mal richtig falsch abgebogen in dem Moment ohne Alternative, weil man muss erst mal Abstand halten und so weiter. Und man war gerade, und das ist ja die Mehrheit, die Armen waren dieser Sachlage einfach ausgeliefert und die Reichen schwebten so ein bisschen über den Verhältnissen. Aber alle haben irgendwie gemerkt, dieses soziale Band, von dem wir immer glaubten, dass es uns zusammenhält, das gibt es so gar nicht. Also nicht nur, es ist verloren gegangen oder so, sondern wir sind so richtig lost eigentlich. Also Corona hat die Gesellschaft so richtig lost gemacht. Und ganz wunderbar, dass er einfach sagt, dem gehen wir jetzt mal auf den Grund mit einer Argumentation, die ich eigentlich schon vor Corona geschrieben habe. Aber jetzt, die noch mal richtig Gravitationen bekommt dadurch. Also einfach ein zufällig sehr guter Einstieg in so einem Buch.
Und die Prämisse ist für unsere Gesellschaft ja die, dass wir sagen, wir müssen die Chancengleichheit erhöhen. Das sagen jetzt nicht alle und sicherlich wird man jetzt bei der Linkspartei nochmal anders über den Begriff wie Chancengleichheit nachdenken. Aber so generell haben wir das schon stark internalisiert, dass wir uns eine hohe Durchlässigkeit wünschen, dass wir sagen, es ist toll, wenn Kinder von Arbeitern studieren können, wenn Leute mit verschiedenen Migrationshintergründen und und und, wenn die alle sich anstrengen können und dann durch Leistung es schaffen können. Daran ist der Bildungsaufstieg geknüpft und der Bildungsaufstieg ist verknüpft mit dem ökonomischen Aufstieg. Da wissen wir jetzt schon seit einiger Zeit, das geht nicht mehr so ganz zusammen. Also es gibt zwar Leute, die diesen Bildungsaufstieg schaffen, aber der kombiniert dann in Ich bin Hanna, man ist sehr gebildet, hat Top-Zensuren, lebt aber sehr prekär und hat einen befristeten Vertrag, der im Sommer schon wieder ausläuft. Das stellt man schon mal fest. Und dann gibt es aber auch noch diese Prämisse, dass mit dieser Chancengleichheit und damit, dass sich alle anstrengen, man eine gerechte Gesellschaft schaffen kann. Und das ist etwas, was für uns ganz fundamental ist und wird ja auch politisch laufend wiederholt. Und Sandel stellt genau das jetzt in Frage. Und ich will gleich ein Zitat vorlesen, um das ein bisschen so zu klären, was eigentlich die Idee hinter dieser meritokratischen, also auf Leistung beruhenden Gesellschaft ist. Sandel schreibt da erstens die Wiederholung der Botschaft, dass wir seien für unser Schicksal selbst verantwortlich und hätten verdient, was wir bekommen. Und das Problem ist, höhlt unter den Bedingungen ausufernder Ungleichheit und zum Stillstand gebrachter gesellschaftlicher Mobilität die Solidarität aus und demoralisiert diejenigen, die von der Globalisierung zurückgelassen wurden. Also das ist ein großes Thema. Wer hat die Globalisierung quasi verloren? Zweitens, darauf zu bestehen, dass ein Uniabschluss der vorrangige Weg zu einem angesehenen Job und einem anständigen Leben sei, sorgt für ein auf Bescheinigungen beruhendes Vorurteil, das die Würde der Arbeit untergräbt und diejenigen erniedrigt, die keine Uni besucht haben. Hier auch was Anekdotisches. Ich hatte in den vergangenen Jahren, wenn ich mal E-Mails oder so bekomme, von Zuschauern immer wieder mal diese Formulierung, ich habe nicht studiert, aber, oder fast so etwas Entschuldigendes. Ich bin noch ein Berger. Wo ich immer gleich drauf geantwortet habe, dass es sich da nicht zu Entschuldigung gibt. Das ist aber für mich eine neue Erfahrung, als ich aus einem Nicht-Akademiker-Haushalt stamm, also der Einzige bin, der eine akademische Laufbahn eingeschlagen hat. Es war aber interessant, dass das schon so verbreitet ist, dass man sich dafür entschuldigt, nicht auf der Uni gewesen zu sein. Und drittens, darauf zu bestehen, dass gesellschaftliche und politische Probleme am besten durch hochgebildete, wertneutrale Experten gelöst werden können, entspricht einer technokratischen Konzeption, die die Demokratie korrumpiert und normale Bürger entmachtet. Und diese drei Überlegungen, die grundieren dieses wirklich hervorragende Buch.
Ja, und ich finde, wenn man es aus einer deutschen Perspektive liest, ist es sogar noch dramatischer als... Wir haben es ja mit einem ura-amerikanischen Text zu tun. Kapitel 1. Wir kennen, das haben wir hier dann auch mitbekommen, diesen Skandal der, wie schleuse ich meinen Nachwuchs in die Uni. Und dann gab es so Agenturen, die sich dann, also viel Geld damit verdient haben, einfach, was weiß ich, das mit dem Sportstipendium so ein bisschen hinzutricksen, die SAT-Scores so ein bisschen und so. Dass man halt einfach in die Unis aufgenommen wird, obwohl man eigentlich nicht wirklich qualifiziert ist. Und das ist natürlich ein ganz eigenamerikanisches Problem, weil das dort die große Bildungshürde ist. Komme ich in die Spitzenunis. Und wir haben ja auch bei Peter Thiel schon gesehen, wie sehr dieses System verhasst wird, auch von denen, die sich es leisten können und so weiter und so fort. Und aus deutscher Sicht können wir ja sagen, bei uns sind die Unis erstmal frei, aber der Weg dahin, ohne dass es große finanzielle Hürden sind, ist genauso gepflastert von all diesen Problemen, die er hier beschreibt. Also selbst wenn die das Problem, und er gibt ja auch konkrete Lösungsvorschläge am Ende dann, selbst wenn die das Problem gelöst bekommen, haben die immer noch das Schulsystem vor der Nase, das genauso schlecht funktioniert wie unseres. Und unter dem Aspekt, finde ich, ist es fast noch schlimmer, als es im Text steht.
Hattest du die Doku damals gesehen bei Netflix?
Nee, die Doku dazu habe ich nicht gesehen.
Es gibt eine Doku darüber, also über diesen Typen, der die Kinder von Reichen an die Elite-Unis gebracht hat. Der hat sich bestechen lassen, bzw. hat dann mit diesem Geld, das er erhalten hat, ja andere bestochen. Und das wurde immer so gemacht, dass man über die Sportvereine da rein ist, dass man dann irgendwelche Zeugnisse ausstellte, die keine Grundlage hatten, ist ein exzellenter Schwimmer und könnte da Großes leisten. Und die Sache war einfach, der Mensch war noch nie im Wasser, und hat auch keine besonders schulisch guten Leistungen. Und deswegen haben aber die reichen Eltern gesagt, gut, wir zahlen mal 150.000. Denn man muss diese Hürde nehmen, man muss diese Zertifikate sammeln. Und das haben wir ja selbst noch bei dem Buch von Adrian Daupe über das Silicon Valley gesehen. Also man muss natürlich erst mal die Elite Uni abbrechen. Also man braucht dann auch dieses Zertifikat, dass man aber zumindest da war und dann sogar so genial ist, dass man noch nicht einmal den Abschluss braucht.
Genau, das ist ganz wichtig. In Deutschland ist immer noch der Abschluss entscheidend. In Amerika ist es die Aufnahme. Und man wird dort auch an den Unis teilweise begrüßt mit. Sie haben es jetzt geschafft. Sie haben die Hürde übersprungen. Egal, was sie jetzt machen, es steht im Lebenslauf drin. Und das ist für Sandels Argument schon so zentral, dass er es als den eigentlichen Einstieg ins Buch, also jetzt Corona-Maus geklammert, dann nimmt. Manche Eltern bezahlen bis zu 1 Mio. Dollar für ihr Kind, um auf diese Unis zu kommen. Princeton, Yale haben mehr Studenten von den top 1% als von dem bottom 60%. Wir haben es also mit einer krassen Ungleichheit, die sich hier einfach über Herkunft und so weiter vererbt zu tun. Allerdings stehen diese Eltern, die haben jetzt nicht irgendwie Möglichkeiten und denken, ich nutze das mal, sondern die selbst stehen unter Druck. Denn sie müssen ihren eigenen Status reproduzieren auf die Kinder. Und das stellt sich vor extreme Herausforderungen, weil auch so ein Scam dadurch zu ziehen ist natürlich nicht ohne. Was für ihn dann wieder heißt, nicht nur die unteren, sondern auch die oberen, also jetzt sozioökonomisch gesehen von oben her, ist es einfach Economic Entity, also die ökonomische Angst, in die Gesellschaft nicht vorwärts zu kommen, die die zentrale Triebfeder für alle ist, bei den Arm wie den Reichen. Und dann steckt da schon mal ein Schlüssel ins Schlüsselloch. Die große Lüge ist eben dieser Gang durch die Hintertür, der illegal, illegitim und damit auch verheimlicht werden muss, muss für die eigene Erzählung als meine Leistung nach außen dargestellt werden. Also das Kind hat es tatsächlich geschafft. Das hat ja nichts Illegales gemacht. Das hat er tatsächlich geschafft. Da schleicht sich so eine Erzählung ein, die, und sei es nur eine Lüge, dann eben wieder reproduziert, was wir als Problem haben. Und dieser Ärger von unten gegen die Eliten und die Angst der Eliten, dass dieses System irgendwann mal kaputt geht und man selber schon merkt, ich schaffe es eigentlich nur noch mit Betrug und so weiter, bringt die Demokratie ins Straucheln. Das sagt er gleich ganz früh. Und wir haben relativ früh eben eine Gewinner- und Verlierer-Aufschlüsselung. Die Ungleichheit als ökonomisches Problem führt zu einer Unzufriedenheit in der ganzen Bevölkerung als kulturelles Problem, das eigentlich für alle so diesen gleichen Strudel bedeutet. Dieses Gefühl, nicht respektiert zu werden, ist Resultat externer Kräfte. Also alle haben so ein bisschen das Gefühl, ich habe es nicht unter Kontrolle. Ich muss hier betrügen oder ich schaffe es erst gar nicht. Meine eigene Leistung ist es nicht. Puh, zum Glück habe ich noch Geld und kann mir irgendwas kaufen. Zum Glück ist unsere Gesellschaft bestechlich. Plötzlich freut man sich darüber, dass die Gesellschaft eigentlich verlogen ist und so. Und das bringt doch alle ins Straucheln. Und dann haben wir eben, muss man überlegen, Peripherie, ja oder nicht, aber die Globalisierungspolitik, die da reinkommt. Er greift ja so auf die letzten 40 Jahre zurück. Also das begegnet uns ja immer wieder so. Dieses Wreckenschlüssel, das alles auf. Man macht hier Trickle-Down. Und das wird ja gerade versucht wieder zu schließen, indem dann Joe Biden jetzt sagt, Trickle-Down has never worked und so. Und dieses Geschichtsbild, dass wir jetzt gerade 2022 so an so einem Punkt sind, wo wir die letzten 40, 50 Jahre noch mal aufschlüsseln, finde ich immer wieder hochinteressant. Und wir kriegen es jetzt aus so vielen Richtungen irgendwie serviert, dass sich so langsam doch ein Bild zusammenbaut, bei dem wir auch alles einbauen können. Unter anderem auch Gerhard Schröder. Also wir haben hier einen Text, der auch aus Gerhard Schröders Regierungserklärung zur Agenda 2010 zitiert, wortwörtlich. Und das finde ich schon besonders, weil der Sandel hat sich hier wirklich bemüht, einfach alle Puzzleteile zusammenzusetzen. Wir haben unglaublich viele Verweise auf Reden von Präsidenten.
Die hat er groß gewertet.
Genau, einzelne Worte.
Die gibt er in digitalisierter Form. Er schaut, wie oft kommt welches Wort vor. Und irgendwann kommt erstaunlich häufig, in den 90ern und 00er Jahren, dass man etwas verdient hat. Das heißt aber auch, die, die etwas nicht haben, die haben es dann offenbar auch nicht verdient. Respekt ist ein Wort, das gleich auf Seite 13 oder so vorkommt. Ein Wort, das wir aus dem Scholz-Wahlkampf kennen, das dann keine weitere Rolle mehr spielt als Begriff. Aber man kann diesen Scholz-Wahlkampf wirklich als eine Illustration des Buches von Sandel erleben. Also das ist plötzlich ganz klar, es ist absolut klar, warum Scholz gegen ein BGE ist. Also dass die Arbeit eine Wertschätzung erfahren soll, im monetären Sinne, wie in dem Sinne einer gesellschaftlichen Anerkennung. Er bringt ja am Ende da auch noch mal ein paar Bezüge zum Beispiel zu Axel Honneth. Aber das ist ganz klar das Scholz-Programm hier als Philosophie bzw. eine Philosophie, aus der sich das Scholz-Programm ableiten lässt. Und diese Erzählung, die du jetzt gerade ja aufgetan hast, da sind Leute, die sind so besessen auf den Erfolg und wissen zugleich, wie verlogen die Gesellschaft ist, dass sie dann Leute bestechen, damit die Sprosslinge eine entsprechende Karriere an der Uni hinlegen können, beziehungsweise dass sie an der Uni aufgenommen werden können. Und dann aber sich im Nachhinein das auch noch so schön reden müssen, dass sie es verdient haben. Das ist etwas, was ja dann für Sandel auch wichtig wird, dass er sagt, ja, aber was heißt denn das eigentlich verdient? Denn das ist ja eine philosophische Frage. Man könnte ja doch zunächst einmal davon ausgehen, dass Leistung in irgendeiner Weise belohnt werden muss. Aber er fragt dann auch sich, ja, aber welche Leistung beloben, welche Leistung loben wir denn da gerade, beziehungsweise zeichnen wir da aus? Es ist ja so, dass wir für unsere Talente, schreibt er, nichts können. Wir haben sicherlich die Komponente des Fleißes, aber es gibt ja noch ganz andere Komponenten, sagt Sandel, die wichtig sind. Dass jemand ein exzellenter Fußballer ist, ist dem ja in die Wiege gelegt. Natürlich muss er daran arbeiten, dass er es auch ist. Also es reicht nicht, einfach nur so ausgestattet zu sein, von der Natur, vom lieben Gott. Da stellt sich ja diese Frage, woher kommt das eigentlich? Aber dafür kann er ja nichts. Während jemand, der genau diese Leistungen nicht erbringen kann, sondern andere Talente hat, ja auch nichts dafür wieder kann. Und deswegen stellt er also aus einer moralischen Überlegung heraus, erst einmal diese Leistungsidee grundsätzlich in Frage. Natürlich hat Erfolg mitunter auch mit Leistung zu tun. Also dass Leute, die ein großes Talent haben, auch kontinuierlich arbeiten müssen. Aber wir haben es ja zum Beispiel mit Leuten zu tun, die ein hohes Talent haben, mit Menschen zusammenzuarbeiten, sie zu pflegen, sie zu erziehen und und und. Und dann haben wir Leute, die haben ein mathematisches Talent, das sie so einsetzen können, dass sie an der Wall Street sehr viel Geld verdienen. Wie kriegen wir das zusammen? Denn wir haben jetzt Leute, die haben doch Talente und die zeigen Leistung. Und trotzdem sind die Verdienste so unterschiedlich. Und dann, wenn man sich das mal klarmacht, dann bricht ganz viel von diesem Leistungsideal zusammen, womit man sich immer so nachträglich alles erklären will. Oder ich will ein ganz einfaches Beispiel noch geben, die zur Komponente des Zufalls und des Glücks. Das ist ja auch etwas, was er stark macht. Das hat ja im Übrigen auch Max Weber schon getan, mit Blick auf seine akademische Karriere. Man versucht im Nachhinein ein Leistungsnarrativ zu entwickeln, das man unglaublich gearbeitet hat, Hard Work und dann hat man es zu etwas gebracht. Aber oft sind es die Zufälle im Leben, die das Entscheidende ausmachen, dass man hart gearbeitet hat und dann glücklicherweise die richtige Person getroffen hat. Um es mal runterzubrechen, es ist ja ein reiner Zufall eigentlich, dass wir hier zusammen jetzt seit über zwei Jahren einen Podcast machen. Zustande gekommen ist, dass du mich irgendwann mal in den Aufwachen-Podcast eingeladen hast. Dann waren wir mal in Frankfurt auf so einer Konferenz und dann hast du mich irgendwann mal angerufen und gesagt, ich glaube, Deutschland braucht einen neuen Podcast. Und da habe ich gesagt, das wusste ich ja noch gar nicht. Und das ist aber einfach der Zufall. Also du hättest ja jetzt auch aus irgendwelchen Gründen sagen können, ich frage jemand anders. Oder ich hätte sagen können, ja, klingt interessant, ich habe aber gerade keine Lust. Was auch immer. Es ist also der Zufall, der uns auch zusammengebracht hat. Das heißt, man muss zwar immer noch jetzt schon regelmäßig einen Podcast anbieten, aber diese Komponente des Zufalls sollte man nicht kleinreden.
Genau, Zufall. Wir nehmen alles auf, was du jetzt gesagt hast und entfalten es nochmal richtig, weil es sich hier richtig anbietet. Der Zufall, das Glück, die Gelegenheit. Wir können auch sagen, die äußeren Umstände. Du hast ja eben schon gesagt, Talent ist in die Wiege gelegt. Man hat gewisse Fähigkeiten, Fertigkeiten kann man erlernen, aber am Ende sind wir alle individuelle Menschen. Wie wir in die Gesellschaft passen, ist fraglich und muss herausgefunden werden. Dafür nehmen wir uns ja auch unendlich viel Zeit, 20 Jahre oder was. Diese äußeren Umstände, und das finde ich diese Kombination von Kapitel 1 und Kapitel 2. Kapitel 2 besprechen wir gleich ganz ausführlich, weil er da wirklich mal einer Ideologie so richtig mit der Spitzhacke bis zum Pinsel an die Wurzeln geht. Und er verkoppelt das aber und sagt, das ist nicht einfach nur Philosophie. Ich schreibe hier nicht irgendwas auf, sondern das hat direkt mit Politik, mit unserem Leben zu tun. Und dieses Gefühl, nicht respektiert zu werden, dieses Gefühl der Haltlosigkeit, ich muss hier die Gesellschaft betrügen, um meine superreichen Kinder unterzubringen oder von unten, ich habe gar keine Chance. Das ist eine Folge äußerer Umstände. Und diese äußeren Umstände sind Folgen der Regierungsarbeit, sagt er ganz deutlich. Die Regierung kann hier etwas tun. Und wenn sie es nicht tut, dann ist das Unterlassung. Und das ist auch eine Handlung. Also auch Unterlassung, Duldung oder so sind politisches Handeln. Und die Frage ist, wie kommen wir zu einem konstruktiven politischen Handeln? Und klar, es ist am Ende immer, das ist vielleicht auch ein bisschen zu einfach. Man muss es trotzdem immer wieder sagen. Es ist dieser Unterschied, diese Ausbalanciung von die Regierung hier und der Markt hier. Jedes Mal, wenn Christian Lindner jetzt sagt, ne, also wir können den Staat nicht mehr verschulden, heißt das ja nur, der Staat soll man nicht so viel Handlungsvermögen erringen, dafür die privaten Investoren umso mehr, damit die Renditen auch wieder privat sind und nicht so viel der Staat was zu verteilen hat. Weil dann bekäme ja jeder was und nicht nur die, die schon von Anfang an mit vielen Investitionen einfach reingegangen sind.
Also das ist eigentlich besser kann man die FDP-Politik nicht zusammenfassen.
Also das ist so die FDP-Ideologie, die genau zwischen Regierung hier, Markt da. Und wir haben jetzt eben einen Kanzler, der diesen Sandel gelesen hat und ihn auch gerne zum Gespräch trifft und so weiter. Und dann haben wir diese Marktideologie der FDP. Und er schlüsselt das hier auf. Er nennt ausdrücklich Gerhard Schröder und auch dieses Hufieren einer neuen, weltläufigen Avantgarde. Da hat sich dann Wagenknecht drüber lustig gemacht, die Selbstgerechten und so weiter. Wir kennen das von Clinton, die Deplore-Bells. Also diese klare Unterscheidung.
Zitierte er ja auch.
Genau, die Gewinner da, die Verlierer da. Und dann ist so ein Schlüsselmoment historisch Obama. Obama macht einen Wahlkampf mit Hoffnung. Und in dem Moment, wo er das weiße Haus betritt, ist alles vorbei. Er twittert nicht mehr. Dieses Hoffnungsmoment ist vorbei. Plötzlich fängt er an, irgendwie zu erzählen. Ja, ja, jeder soll hier und so weiter. Wir geben euch die Möglichkeiten und ihr setzt sie dann um. Also jeder hat sein eigenes Glückes Schmied.
Ja, jeder kann seinen Träumen folgen oder auf den Wogen seines Traumes. Das ist so eine gewisse Formulierung, die findet dann Obama so toll, dass man seinen Träumen folgen kann, soweit sie einen tragen. Und das will er einfach nur ermöglichen, dass jeder dann quasi der Leistungsgesellschaft entsprechen kann und dann seine Talente verwirklichen kann. Dass er das, glaube ich, 30-mal oder so in seiner Amtszeit in Reden verwendet. Also das ist immer ganz interessant. Wenn es nicht nur so ein, zwei, drei Sätze sind, die mal irgendwo aufgeschnappt sind, dann könnte man ja sagen, na ja, Politiker reden viel, wenn der Tag lang ist. Aber bei Sandel hat das auch eine gewisse Empirie, dass er sagt, das wurde halt 40- bis 50-mal verwendet von Präsident Reagan oder von Obama oder Clinton. Schaut er sich ja auch genau an, auch so Aussagen wie, ja, ich habe in den Wahlkreisen gewonnen, die das höchste BIP haben. Und dann sagt er ja klar, was bedeutet denn das eigentlich, was sie da äußert?
Genau, also bei Obama, jeder soll soweit kommen, Zitat, wie ihre Talente und ihr Arbeitsethos und ihre Träume sie tragen. Das ist so der Slang im Original-Wortlaut von Obama. Währenddessen allerdings steht die Welt kopfökonomisch. Irgendwelche Ökonome rennen ins Oval Office rein und sagen, also sie müssen jetzt Goldman Sachs retten mit einer Billion Dollar, sonst fliegt ja alles da nieder. Also wird plötzlich eine Billion Dollar neu verteilt. Also jetzt, ich habe mir das jetzt ausgedacht, sowohl die Bank als auch, aber wir wissen ja noch, als die ganzen Versicherer da pleiteging und so und da wirklich gestützt werden musste. Plötzlich stehen Milliarden und Milliarden neues Geld zur Verfügung, finden auch ihren Weg in die Gesellschaft, werden neu verteilt. Diejenigen, die davon profitieren, wissen selbst nicht, wie ihnen geschieht. Und wie erklären sie sich? Na, wir sind natürlich die Gewinner. Ich weiß gar nicht, warum die anderen davon nicht profitieren konnten. Was ist denn mit denen falsch gelaufen und so, ja? Und während Obama also so redet, wie er redet, ich, der erste schwarze Präsident, ermögliche jedem, weil ich bin ja der Präsident. Quarant kann ich das ja irgendwie befehlen oder so. Und es gärt halt, zuerst kommt die Tea Party und dann kommt Trump. Also es ist einfach rückblickend gesehen, ja klar, eins plus eins ist eben zwei, wenn man es hart drauf anlegt. Und man hatte ja eben nochmal richtig hart es drauf angelegt. Obama ist sozusagen der letzte Ausläufer dieser Anthony Gittens, Blair, Schröder. Wir machen so einen neuen dritten Weg. Wir versuchen irgendwas, Markt und Regierung. Wir schaffen doch irgendwie beides. Alles ist Public-Private-Partnership. Aber es ist eben am Ende doch nur Korruption und Betrug. Jeder versucht so seinen kleinen Vorteil reinzuholen. Und wir haben eine Explosion der Ungleichheit. Während die Top 1 mehr als jemals verdienen und wir mittlerweile die größten Vermögen der Welt auf einzelne Personen in dreistelliger Milliardenzahl rechnen, die untere Hälfte stagniert oder verliert. Also kam keinen Schritt vorwärts und damit... Tja, haben wir auf der einen Seite diesen großen populistischen Anger, wie er sagt. Also man ist wirklich wütend und organisiert diese Wut auch. Wir haben eine Chancenungleichheit, wir haben einen ausgeträumten amerikanischen Traum, wir haben keine soziale Mobilität mehr. Obwohl Mobilität so lange ein für viele nachvollziehbarer Weg einfach war, dem man gehen konnte. Beispielsweise über die ganze Bildungsinvasion. Das haben wir ja bei Mark Scheritz auch ganz deutlich gelesen. Wie Olaf Scholz diesen Willy-Branchen-Aufstieg durch Bildung ablehnt. Weil das einfach eine große Lüge war.
Und weil es auch grundsätzlich in Frage zu stellen ist. Also das finde ich so toll, dass Sandel, wir haben ja schon einige Texte und auch Bücher über den Neoliberalismus gelesen, die auch diese Diagnosen für uns parat halten. Die sagen, stimmt aber nicht. Die Reichen sind reicher geworden, die Armen ärmer. Und der nächsten Generation geht es keineswegs besser als den Eltern. Das war noch in den 70ern so, das war in den 80ern so. Und dann bröckelte das einfach so dahin. Aber Sandel ist ja jemand, der sagt, ja, es ist aber ein grundsätzlich falsches Denken zu meinen, dass die Gesellschaft als Ganzes nach vorne kommt und dass es mehr Zusammenhalt gibt, dass es allen besser geht, wenn man auf diese radikale Chancengleichheit setzt. Denn diese produziert ja ständig ganz, ganz viele Verlierer. Und das muss man begreifen. Also selbst wenn man sagt, wir haben absolute Chancengleichheit geschaffen, dann hat man keine gerechte Gesellschaft geschaffen. Und gerade bei dem Unisystem können wir sehen, selbst wenn, und er bringt ja dann ja nachher ein Beispiel, wo das auch sehr stark diversifiziert wurde und wo Leistung das Entscheidende wurde, selbst wenn das gelingt, haben wir es nicht mit einem gerechten System zu tun, weil wir eigentlich permanent Verlierer produzieren. Und diese Verlierer, die sehen sich auch als Verlierer und werden angesprochen, zum Beispiel von einem Donald Trump, der die Welt einteilt in Gewinnen und Verlieren, der gar nicht mehr kommt mit der Stufenleiter, die man nach oben klettern kann und mit den Träumen, denen man folgen soll, sondern es gibt Verlierer und Gewinner. Und diese Einteilung ist dann plötzlich eine, die diese ganze Gesellschaft einteilt und auch das Denken strukturiert.
Genau, und es ist immer noch eine große Frage, ist das Genialität von Trump oder ist er Instinkten gefolgt? Denn er kam nicht als der Erlöser wie der Kindergartencop, der einfach sagt, wir machen jetzt mal aus eurem Pudding Muskeln, sondern der den einfach sagt, ja, ihr seid die Verlierer, die Clinton findet das auch, aber ich identifiziere mich jetzt mit euch. Ich bin für euch da und ich sage euch nicht, lest mal mehr Bücher und strengt euch mehr an, sondern ich sage euch, die Chinesen sind schuld und diese Einwanderer und überhaupt. Und wir externalisieren jetzt mal alle Probleme. Klar, alles super einfache Antworten, aber diese Idee, sagen wir mal, diese aufgeklärte demokratische Idee von, naja, dann müssen wir jetzt mal alle fördern und so weiter, aus Verlierern Gewinner machen. Das ist das eine. Aber Sandels Ansatz, einfach grundsätzlich zu sagen, schon das Produzieren von Verlierern ist einfach totaler Quatsch. Um vorauszuspringen, das Bildungskapitel ist ihm ja extrem wichtig, das Bildungsthema, deswegen hat es mehrere Kapitel. Er sagt ja am Ende, es ist total albern, dass solche Top-Unis einfach damit werben auch, dass bei ihnen nur 5% der Bewerber rankommen. Damit produziert man 95% Leute, die einfach Briefe oder Briefkassen bekommen. Dein Lebensentwurf ist leider gescheitert. Wir lassen ihn scheitern, du bist ein Verlierer. Er kommt ja mit diesem Los-System. Man könnte ja einfach sagen, man macht so einen riesen Pot auf. Alle, die qualifiziert sind, sind da drin. Und dann entscheidet das Los. Man wird einfach nach Zufall aussortiert, um schon mal diesen Druck rauszunehmen. Du bist nicht an der Uni, also du bist ein Verlierer, sondern nein, du hast die Qualifikation genommen. Du bist zwar trotzdem nicht an der Uni, aber das war nur Zufall. Das war einfach nur Zufall, das war Schicksal. Und damit käme man auch schon, also damit kämen so 35-45% der Bewerber in Harvard, Princeton und wo auch immer kämen mit so was in ihrem Lebenslauf schon ein bisschen weiter als einfach mit, ja sie sind leider abgelehnt, wir können denen gar nicht sagen, warum und so. Sondern wenn man da einfach...
Das ist so wie, wenn man sagt, ich habe leider nicht im Lotto gewonnen, da wird jetzt niemand sagen, oh, da ist doch was Schlimmes, da warst du aber schuld.
Du hast das Glücksspiel nicht gewonnen. Also das würde man ja nicht sagen. Genau. Und ja, also Trump ist sozusagen diese Zäsur, macht er ganz klar, zieht er. Und das finde ich auch gut. Denn damit ist auch dieses Eingeständnis, es gibt diese Art der Verlierer. Wir brauchen aber einen anderen Umgang mit ihm. Vielleicht schon, weil wir die Maßstäbe mal, die jemanden zum Verlierer erklären, einfach alle mal ausräumen oder hinterfragen können. Ist da schon mal so ein Vlog eingeschlagen, wo ich denke, ja genau in die Richtung sollte man das jetzt irgendwie mal denken und ich fand es dann doch irgendwie auch sehr, wie soll man sagen, es erwischt einen ja so ein bisschen, wenn so Ideen im Text stehen, bei denen man denkt, ja stimmt irgendwie, denn wir, wie soll man sagen, diese Verkopplung aus Meritokratie, also harte Leistungsabrechnung, Bilanzierung und Moralsystem und Moral ist ja am Ende dann doch so die generalisierten Achtungsbedingungen. Wie begegnen wir uns eigentlich? Wie gehen wir aufeinander? Achten wir uns oder nicht? Also diese Verkopplung steckt ja nun ganz tief drin in so einer Idee von, wir sind ja in Deutschland geboren und hier gibt es ja eine Grenze. Und warum leiden die eigentlich jenseits der Grenze? Und wir können uns einfach nur sagen, wir haben halt Glück gehabt. In der Verlosung des Lebens sind wir halt an einer anderen Stelle geboren worden. Und alle Besitztümer, die wir jetzt auf uns beziehen und nicht einfach spenden, der Allgemeine zur Verfügung stellen, sind in der Hinsicht entlang dieses Systems irgendwie dann auch so ein, wir haben jetzt niemanden betrogen, um uns in Deutschland sesshaft zu machen.
Nee, das ist Geburtenroulette.
Aber da steckt so eine, es sind halt die äußeren Umstände. Also schon an diesem Punkt einfach zu sagen, es ist nicht meine Leistung. Und alles, was ich jetzt morgen machen kann, weil mir die Möglichkeiten gegeben sind, sind auch nicht meine Leistung, sondern da einfach wirklich anzuerkennen, dass es Zufall ist. Und das auch in so ein Weltbild aufzunehmen.
Demut ist ja ein wichtiges Wort. Damit endet ja das Buch. Das Buch endet mit Demut. Ich bin bei dem Begriff vorsichtig, wenn man einfach mit Demut im kirchlichen Sinne Leuten sagt, du brauchst aber auch gar nichts. Also sei mal demütig. Aber dass man so eine grundsätzliche Demut entwickelt über das, was da ist, in dem Sinne, dass man es irgendwie zufällig bekommen hat, plus dann das entsprechende Land, in dem man lebt, dass das einen tatsächlich diese Leistungsideologie ja schon ganz grundsätzlich hinterfragen lässt. Da sind wir ja noch gar nicht bei irgendwelchen Aufnahmetests. Da sind wir noch gar nicht dabei, was er auch sehr gut beschreibt, dass diese Aufnahmetests natürlich auch so an den Universitäten schon strukturiert sind, dass reiche Leute sie gut trainieren können und wieder Geld dafür zahlen, dass sie mit Nachhilfestunden diese Aufnahmetests schaffen. Da sind wir ja dann noch gar nicht. Aber auch das sind dann alles Punkte, die immer zeigen, nein, das ist nicht neutral. Und der zeigt auch, weil du das schon angesprochen hast, jetzt bei dieser Verlosung von Uni-Plätzen, da würde man auch erst mal so zurückschrecken und sagen, ja, aber das geht doch nicht, dass das einfach so ist. Und dann hat er ja Beispiele von Spitzensportlern, die ganz, ganz schlecht eingeschätzt wurden. Also die erfolgreichsten Sportler der Welt, wenn man sich ansieht, wie die mal eingeschätzt wurden, dann hat man gesagt, ja, so 199. Stelle irgendwo.
Genau, Tom Brady wäre fast nicht zum Tugel gekommen. Die haben da ihre Sichtungstage. Alle sollen mal 60 Meter laufen und einen Ball werfen. Und es korreliert überhaupt nicht mit der Karriere, die am Ende dann daraus kommt.
Und wenn das selbst, sagt er bei so was ganz Spezielles. Also wo man ja einfach nur guckt, kann der weit werfen, kann er schnell laufen, kann er hoch springen. Also wurde das ja wirklich so was ganz, ganz klar, sagt er. Wenn man das schon nicht zuverlässig sagen kann, ja wie soll man dann sagen, ja das wird ein großartiger Biologe sein? Wie will man denn so eine Aussage treffen? Wie will man das überhaupt prüfen?
Genau. So, also Kapitel 2. Groß, weil gut heißt es auf Deutsch, ich weiß nicht, wie es auf Englisch heißt. Also ich habe das Buch hauptsächlich auf Englisch gehört, parallel aber im Browser auf Deutsch mitlaufen lassen, um mir dann so der Ansicht, ich war ein bisschen zu schwach, um es einfach konzentriert mit den Augen zu lesen. Und nun gut, also dieses Kapitel 2. Das ist einfach meine Empfehlung, dieses Kapitel 2 aus diesem Buch. Groß, weil gut. Und die Ideologie, an der wir anhängen, lässt sich auf einen kleinen Nenner bringen. Wir sind unseres Schicksals Schmied. Dieser profane deutsche Satz findet aber in diesem Text nicht statt, sondern das ist einfach meine Verkürzung. Und wir erleben...
Nee, die Idee ist, also der ursprüngliche Satz ist, der immer wieder wiederholt wird von Politikern. Amerika ist groß, weil es gut ist. Das ist eine Formulierung, die Präsidenten oder Kandidaten wie Hillary Clinton immer wieder wiederholt haben. Und gerade das sollte man infrage stellen, sagt er.
Genau. Und wir nähern uns diesem... Also da am Ende in der Politik kumuliert es so auf so einer gesellschaftstragenden Rolle. Wir haben so Freiheitserleben, weil wir einfach die Möglichkeiten unseres Lebens glauben, selbst geschaffen zu haben, also können wir sie auch ausbeuten. Wir gehen also mit dem Verdienst oder was auch immer, den wir haben, in die Gesellschaft und toben uns aus. Jeder ist für sich verantwortlich und damit auch an sich selbst schuld. Und diese Merit-Ideologie ist ein kosmisches Gesetz. Irgendwo im Hintergrund ist also auch für uns heute noch ein schaffender und strafender Gott, der uns immer präsent ist und sei es nur durch. Wir können es uns nicht erklären, also irgendwas muss ja noch da sein. Man hat dann so eine Hintergrundgläubigkeit, die man aber nie explizit auslebt oder so. Man geht jetzt nicht deswegen in die Kirche. Muss man auch nicht. Und super interessant ist, wie er eben einfach sagt, unsere moderne ökonomische Gerechtigkeitsdiskussion tragen wir, wie Kinder, die ihre primäre Sozialisation noch so nicht durchschauen, sondern einfach mitschleifen, vor einer Kulisse religiöser Paradigmen aus, die wir eigentlich dachten, überwunden zu haben. Wir leben nicht im 16. Jahrhundert oder so, sondern wir leben ja in der modernen Welt. Und trotzdem spielt das immer noch so eine tragende Rolle, wie zum Beispiel die TU DC. Also die Frage, warum gibt es Leid in der Welt? Gott ist doch ein Guter und er hat doch einen Überblick und so. Warum leidet denn jemand? Und klar, Gott ist gerecht und allmächtig, schreibt Sandel. Aber es gibt eben immer auch das Böse. Also der Teufel und so, dieser Kontrapunkt, der Antipode, der ist halt immer da. Und damit ist auch schon mal erste Orientierung gegeben. Es gibt Gottes Weg, auf dem können wir auch sein. Abseits davon gibt es aber auch einen Weg zum Bösen, einen Weg des Schlechten. Und wenn man sich auf dem befindet, dann hat man das aus freien Stücken getan, weil man hat einen Gottesweg verlassen. Das kann man für sich selbst oder bei anderen so sehen. Also wenn man so einen Bettler begegnet und so weiter, ja wieso hat denn der nicht Gottes Weg gewählt? Warum ist denn der so arm? Er wird schon irgendwelche Gründe haben. Wahrscheinlich konnte er irgendwas nicht verkraften und hat irgendwann den Mut verloren, den wir aber alle noch hatten. Deswegen konnten wir es geschafft und der eben nicht. Und er erinnert dann an Pelagius, ein Mönch im fünften Jahrhundert. Zitat, obwohl er nicht besonders bekannt ist, haben einige Kommentatoren in jüngster Zeit gemeint, Pelagius sei als Verfechter des freien Willens und der individuellen Verantwortung in der frühen christlichen Theologie ein Vorläufer des Liberalismus gewesen. Also diese Verklammerung von Religion früher und ökonomischer Ideologie heute ist da ziemlich hoch. Damals gab es aber diesen Widerspruch von Augustinus. Nee, freier Wille ist nicht, weil all Macht Gottes. Wir können ja jetzt nicht Gott aus dem Bild nehmen und uns da irgendwie reinsetzen. Eine Diskussion, die wir dann bis zu Luther und so weiter führten. Falls die Menschen so unabhängig seien, dass sie aus eigener Kraft Erlösung erlangen könnten, werde die Menschwertung Gottes überflüssig. Demut angesichts der Gnade Gottes werde durch Stolz auf die eigene Anstrengung verdrängt. Und da sieht man schon mal Demut als Konzept, hier noch ganz religiös gedacht, kann ersetzt werden durch Stolz. Und mit Stolz ist hier schon gemeint die völlige Übertreibung des Bezugs auf einen selbst. Dass man eben nicht von Äußereinflüssen, nicht von irgendeiner Gottesgnade, nicht von was weiß ich, was einem die Eltern als Erbe mitgeben oder sonstigen, dass man einfach behauptet, ich habe es gemacht, ich bin stolz auf mich.
Ich habe es verdient, ich habe hart gearbeitet.
Genau, und dieser Stolz ist ja in unserer Sozialisation, gerade dadurch, dass wir jetzt in den letzten 30, 40 Jahren viel so über Lob, nicht so sehr über Bestrafung, sondern über Lob, also das Kind in dem Moment, wo es was Außergewöhnliches oder für sich erstmaliges usw., loben wir es einfach, um es zu bestärken. Also wir sind ja genau auf diesem Stolztrip eigentlich, bis es dann total schief geht, weil es ist leider kein toller Schwimmer geworden, aber kommt trotzdem über die Schwimmschiene, weil die Eltern noch mal eine Million nachschieben usw., dann in diese Uni rein. Also da korrumpiert und pervertiert es in dem Mann auch komplett. Und dann beginnt er diese, da hat es mich dann wirklich auch, das muss ich mir dann auch noch ein paar Mal durchlesen, aber als er dann auf diesen Kalvinismus zu sprechen kommt. Wir haben den Stolz auf die eigenen Leistungen. Oder das komplette Gegenkonzept, nämlich es ist Gottes Gnade. Und wir haben nicht mal einen freien Wilden. Also wir können nicht nur nicht gut für uns entscheiden, sondern wir können gar nicht entscheiden. Wir sind ihm ausgeliefert. Und da oszilliert so ein bisschen unsere Schicksalshaftigkeit im Sinne von, wo ist eigentlich mein Platz im Leben und so. Wo ist mein Platz in der Welt?
Ja, und er greift ja als Soziologe dann hier eigentlich was auf, was von Max Weber ausgearbeitet wurde. Diese protestantische Arbeitsethik als eine ganz wichtige ideologische Grundlage für den modernen Kapitalismus. Thomas Mann hat behauptet, ja, ja, das habe ich aber schon alles vorweggenommen, nämlich in den Bodenbrucks. Das stimmt auch in gewisser Weise. Und die Idee bei dieser Ausprägung des Protestantismus, also des Kalbinismus, der hier beschrieben wird, ist ja auch die des Erwähltseins, ohne davon zu wissen, ob man wirklich erwählt ist. Also man bekommt ja nicht irgendwann mal von Gott das Signal gesendet, hallo hier, du bist erwählt. Aber man kann natürlich durch eigene Leistung, das ist ja die Ideologie, und dann einem beruflichen Fortkommen und einem ökonomischen Fortkommen darauf schließen, dass man wahrscheinlich erwählt worden ist von Gott. Denn sonst wäre man ja nicht so erfolgreich. Und zugleich ist man nur so erfolgreich, weil man sich ja anstrengt, so erfolgreich zu sein. Das ist eine ganz ja fast paradoxe Situation, die da das Subjekt hinein gegeben wird.
Genau. Paradox in dem Sinne, er sagt auch häufiger, psychologisch sind wir wirklich bereit, irgendwann mal alles zu spenden. Dafür leben wir aber hier in Frieden und nicht im Südsudan oder so. Bis dahin will man es ja irgendwie treiben. Und mit diesem Demut und Stolz-Gegensatz und dieser kalvinistischen Idee, wir sind von Gott auserwählt. Und nur deswegen sind wir hier. Was ja dann zu so einer religiösen, also auf religiösem Fundament steht, eine Aussage führt, wie mir geht es gut, weil ich dann zu den Guten gehöre. Sonst hätte mich Gott ja nicht ausgewählt. Sonst wäre ich ja irgendwann, oder gar nicht, oder wie auch immer. Und da kam für mich schon mal der Gedanke auf, wenn wir dieses religiöse Konzept einfach übernehmen, in so eine ökonomische Idee von, ja, du kannst stolz auf deine eigene Leistung sein, wenn nicht, dann halt nicht. Dann bist du halt so ein Ungnade Gottes gefallen. Es gibt ja diesen trostspendenden Satz, du kannst nicht tiefer fallen als in Gottes Hände. Wenn du dich einverstanden erklärst, ein demütiges Leben führst usw., dann kann dir im Grunde nichts passieren, weil du kannst nicht tiefer fallen als in Gottes Hände. In dem Moment, wo aber so ein Kosmos aufgemacht wird mit, naja, es gibt schon so einen Weg abseits von Gott. Und es gibt schon so einen Weg, wo man auch scheitern kann. Weil die sind ja nicht ohne Grund stolz auf sich. Du kannst halt nicht stolz auf dich sein. Dann eröffnet sich da auch die Perspektive, dass man tatsächlich tiefer fallen als in Gottes Hände. Also dass jeder, der heute ökonomisch scheitert, nicht mal mehr von einem Gott oder so noch aufgefangen wird. Nicht mal in der Gemeinde noch Anerkennung findet oder sonst irgendwie. Einfach nur, wie Mark Schiritz das bei Olaf Scholz schrieb, wir müssen jetzt erstmal Menschen akzeptieren und anerkennen, nur weil sie da sind. Ich habe das zufällig gestern in den Rentnerpublik geschrieben. Die Grundrente war ja für uns so ein ganz kleines, oder halt nochmal so eine Grundrente, so eine Grundlage eingeführt irgendwie, oder auch der Mindestlohn. Nur in diesem Wechselspiel von Markt, Tier und Politik da ist der Mindestlohn, der jetzt auf 12 Euro erhoben wird, und die Grundrente sind politische Entscheidungen gegen den Markt. Ganz explizit. Denn da greift nicht mehr die Rentenformel und beim Mindestlohn greift nicht mehr die Preisfindung des Marktes nach Angebot und Nachfrage, sondern es wird durch eine politisch pauschale Entscheidung einfach gesagt, unter diesem Wert kriegt niemand eine Rente, der länger als 35 Jahre gearbeitet hat. Aber es gibt einfach eine Jahreszahl, egal wie dein Verdienst da war, egal was die Rentenformel sagt oder sonstiges, greift alles nicht. Die Politik hat gesagt, deine Grundrente ist diese. Also wird einfach der Markt so richtig außer Kraft gesetzt. Das ist beim Mindestlohn auch. Wenn du arbeitest, kriegst du einen Mindestlohn, auch wenn die Ware selbst am Ende unter diesem Verkauf wird. Dann muss ich das Unternehmen irgendwas überlegen und sei es, was weiß ich wie, Subventionsideen und so. Es gibt so neue Haltelinien in der Politik. Das war unter Merkel undenkbar. Das ist aber mit Hubertus Heil und Olaf Scholz zumindest schon mal im Finanzministerium und jetzt im Kanzleramt ist sowas plötzlich möglich.
Ich merke an, dass Merkel aus einem protestantischen Pfarrhaus ist.
Ja, und das ist eben dieser Punkt, dieser Protestantismus. Denn es steht die Reformation an. Und Luther kommt eben noch mal und sagt, nein, wir können uns nicht aus Gottes Gnade einfach herauskaufen durch eigene ökonomische Kraft. Nur wer jemand besonders viel Goldstücke verdient hat, kann nicht einfach in die Kirche gehen und sagen, ich kaufe mich jetzt zurück in Gottes Gnade. Also diese harte Trennung von demütigen, auf Gottes Wegen geführten Leben und der ökonomischen Realität und sei mal stolz darauf, dass du so viel Geld verdient hast, das darf nicht kompatibel werden.
Aber Luther bezieht das nicht, das fand ich ganz interessant von Sandel, nicht darauf, dass er jetzt sagt, er will zurück zu diesem demütigen Konzept von Gottes Gnade, sondern Luther sagt eigentlich, ja, das ist ja nicht richtig erarbeitet. Also ihn würde jetzt an dem Unisystem in den USA nicht stören, dass es diese Leistungsgesellschaft gibt. Und würde ein Demut einfordern, sondern ihn würde nur stören, dass da Kinder einfach Geld bekommen und damit die entsprechende Laufbahn machen können. Aber grundsätzlich wäre er, also ich versuche das jetzt auch ein bisschen runterzudauen, ich bin ja selbst Protestant, wenn man so will, wenn auch vielleicht anderer Natur. Und es ist aber bei Luther tatsächlich dieser Gedanke, dass man also durch die eigene Leistung, also das heißt durch das Beten, durch den Glauben dorthin kommen kann. Und das ist dann etwas, also dieser Leistungsgedanke, auch dieser Individualismus im Glauben, also da ist ja nicht mehr die kirchliche Institution so wichtig im Protestantismus, sondern ich allein bin es und ich allein muss auch mit der Last umgehen. Der Sünde kann nicht mir mal gerade irgendwo Absolution verschaffen. Das ist etwas, was dann sehr sehr prägend wird für den modernen und den frühen Kapitalismus.
Also hier ist eine wirklich schwere Nuss zu knacken, denn dieser Weg von der religiösen zur ökonomischen Lebensrealität ist nicht so einfach zu gehen. Und an zwei Zitaten aus dem Text kann man es glaube ich so ein bisschen aufschlüsseln. Zum einen schreibt Sandel wie Luther, behauptete auch Johannes Calvin, dessen Theologie die Puritana inspirierte, dass Erlösung von der Gnade Gottes Abhänge, also dass Erlösung von der Gnade Gottes Abhänge und nicht durch menschliche Leistung oder Verdienst bestimmt sei. Wer erlöst und wer verdammt wird, ist vorbestimmt und nicht dadurch veränderbar, wie Menschen ihr Leben leben. Okay, soweit.
Also das würde erstmal darauf schließen, man kann gar nichts ausrichten. Das ist ja das, was daraus folgen würde.
Wir sind ausgeliefert. Es gibt aber das Verdienstvolle und das Verdammte Leben. Also Gott kann entscheiden, diese Unterscheidung ist klar. Und dann schreibt er ein bisschen später, Zitat, für unsere Zwecke liegt die Bedeutung dieses Dramas jedoch in der Spannung, die sich zwischen Verdienst und Gnade entwickelt. Lebenslange, disziplinierte Arbeit in seiner Berufung ist kein Weg zur Erlösung. Sie ermöglicht einem vielmehr zu erfahren, ob man bereits zu den Auserwählten gehört. Sie ist ein Zeichen der Erlösung, nicht ihr Ursprung.
Und das ist das Perfideste überhaupt. Das heißt nämlich, wenn man es ja wüsste, man ist erlöst oder nicht, dann kann man ja auch sonst den lieben Gott einen guten Mann sein lassen und dann kann man ja einfach machen, was man will. Aber indem man sagt, kann sein, kann aber auch nicht sein, aber ich empfehle dir doch sehr, dich anzustrengen. Und wenn du erfolgreich bist, dann wirst du das damit erfahren, dass du es bist, dass du erlöst bist, dass du zu den Auserwählten gehörst. Das ist etwas, was alle an die Kandare nimmt und was natürlich Verlierer ohne Ende produziert.
Genau, weil das heißt ja erst mal, die Gnade Gottes ist dir gegeben, aber du kannst sie verspielen. Damit rückt der Calvinismus am Ende, nämlich doch die Arbeitszentrum des Lebens, also des Individuellen und damit auch die Ökonomie ins Zentrum der Gesellschaft. Deswegen auch Max Weber's protestantische Ethik und der Geist des Kapitalismus. Also diese Verknüpfung, schon in der Überschrift. Zwischen diesen beiden Zitaten, die ich gerade vorgelesen habe aus dem Text, kommt diese Auflistung, wann amerikanische Präsidenten und Präsidentinnen und Präsidenten, Anwärterinnen davon sprechen, dass Amerika ein großes Land ist, weil es gut ist. Also wo genau dieser Calvinismus auf so eine neokalvinistische, wir sind die Guten, weil uns gut geht, fast vulgär kalvinistische, eben genau mit diesem, ihr müsst es aber auch beweisen, verdreht wird. Und da ist eben zentral Clinton 2016, wie sie dann, Zitat aus ihrer Rede, am Ende läuft es darauf hinaus, was Donald Trump nicht versteht, Amerika ist groß, weil Amerika gut ist. So, und jetzt ist halt die Frage, hat Trump da echt was nicht verstanden, oder ist er seinem Gefühl gefolgt? Kann man jetzt jedem so ein Sandelbuch vorlegen, dem Wählern, ja, und das irgendwie aufschlüsseln? Nein, sondern wir haben es hier mit so einer vulgär kalvinistischen, wir sind irgendwie Gott ausgeliefert, wir können es aber auch verspielen. Und jeder Einzelne kann es verspielen. Du bist am Ende deines Schicksals Schmied, wenn du es ökonomisch nicht schaffst, hast du nicht nur kein Geld verdient, sondern auch Gottes Gnade verloren. Du bist ein echter Loser. Du bist ein Richard Deplorable. Das steckt also drin, wenn Präsidenten dann so reden.
Und das finde ich so erstaunlich, wenn er immer schaut, wann wurde das eigentlich zuerst gesagt? Und Eisenhower hat das mal gesagt, dass Amerika groß ist, weil Amerika gut ist. Und das hat er aber damals noch zugeschrieben, Alexis de Tocqueville, der ja dieses berühmte Buch über die amerikanische Demokratie im 19. Jahrhundert verfasst hat. Das ist aber gar kein Zitat von ihm. Aber dann war das etwas, was entsprechend die Präsidenten immer wieder aufgenommen haben. Bush und so weiter und so weiter. Immer wieder haben dann in den 90er Jahren auch die Demokraten begonnen. Diesen Satz, Amerika ist groß, weil Amerika gut ist, zu verwenden in ihren Reden. Und das ist ja etwas, was wir dann eigentlich so komplett internalisiert haben, wenn es auch um geopolitische Konflikte, sprich um Kriege geht, dass wir diese Argumentation vorfinden. Oder wir finden sie auch wieder, also diese kalvinistische Idee, weil jetzt sicherlich viele sagen, naja, aber was habe ich mit dem Kalvinismus zu tun? Also wir finden die in unserer Gesellschaft laufend wieder, weil wir immer wieder auch diese Formulierung verwenden. Du hast es dir aber auch verdient. Also das ist etwas, du hast auch ein Recht darauf. Das ist auch eine Formulierung, die wir immer wieder hören. Und wir können es dann auch ganz konkret sehen. Wir hatten, glaube ich, mal einen Text dazu im Salon, wie die Evangelikalen aus Amerika eine unglaubliche Weltkarriere hinlegen, in dem sie plötzlich in Südkorea ungeheuer gefragt sind. Dass wir also diese Ideologie, Erfolg und Glaube miteinander neoliberal verquicken, ist etwas, was wir in lateinamerikanischen Länder sehen, was wir in Korea erleben können, was wir wahrscheinlich zunehmend auch hier in Europa erleben können.
Genau, da schlicht sich so eine Ideologie ein, die hochattraktiv ist, aus verschiedenen Gründen und die eben zu dieser und dann, da schwenkt es dann auch um, über das Gemeinwohl zu sprechen, Zitat, wenn der Glaube an Gott zurückweicht, gewinnt das Zutrauen in menschliches Handeln an Kraft. Das ist das, was wir mit den Bildungsversprechen jedem Kind mitgeben wollen. Je mehr wir uns selbst als erselbstermächtig und autark konzipieren, desto weniger Gründe haben wir, für unseren Erfolg Verpflichtung oder Dankbarkeit zu empfinden. Wir haben also zum einen die Demut ausgetrieben und damit auch ein Konzept, dass es noch andere Gründe gibt als dich selbst. Das hast du vorhin schon angesprochen. Die Demain Intervention. Dass man sagt, das ist ein krasser Zufall. Wie kann das denn sein? Dass Glück einfach so... Da ist aber was Krasses passiert. Das ist ja wirklich erstaunlich, dass sich so ein Augenblick in diese Richtung ausbeuten lässt. Wenn man das dann richtig runterbricht auf die politische Realität, die wir haben, indem einfach wir jetzt... Das ist ja die Tyranny of Merit. Dass wir ganz nach vorne so ein Konzept des persönlichen, unsozialen Triumphs stellen. Vorrangig ökonomisch. Dann haben wir es z.B. mit der Wohnkostendiskussion zu tun. Jemand verdient eine Rendite auf eine Immobilie, die ihm irgendwann mal jemand vererbt hat. Diese Rendite kommt...
Die hab ich verdient.
Da hab ich viel reingesteckt in die Wohnung. Diese Rendite kommt aber nur zustande, weil diese Wohnung irgendwo steht, wo sich jemand um U-Bahn-Verbindungen, tolle Kneipen, tolle Bildungseinrichtungen, tolle Infrastruktur kümmert. Nichts davon geht auf die Leistung des Vermieters zurück. Aber er streicht diese Rendite zu 100% ein, weil es seins ist. In solchen Sachen gipfelt diese verquere Ethologie. Dass man da wirklich glaubt, das ist doch mein Verdienst. Wir haben auch im Grundgesetz Eigentum verpflichtet. Aber nicht Renditen. Man hat kein Recht auf Renditen. Das steht nirgendwo. Eigentum verpflichtet. Das ist eigentlich ungedreht gemeint. Du hast eine Wohnung in Berlin, und sehr viele junge Leute wollen da leben. Dann werden wir deiner Verantwortung gerecht. Ich habe doch ein Recht auf Rendite. Recht auf Rendite steht nirgendwo geschrieben. Das ist einfach nur diese Ethologie, die sich hier so reingetrieben hat und gegen die wir gerade nichts machen können.
Blicken wir noch ganz kurz nach China, weil ich diesen Absatz hoch interessant fand. Es ist ein sehr amerikanisches Buch, aber dennoch erfahren wir auch etwas über China. Da schreibt Sandel, die meritokratische Grundhaltung, die ich bei den Studenten bemerkt habe, ist kein ausschließlich amerikanisches Phänomen. 2012 hielt ich an der Xiamen-Universität an der Südostküste Chinas einen Vortrag. Mein Thema waren die moralischen Grenzen von Märkten. Zeitungen hatten kurz zuvor von einem chinesischen Teenager berichtet, der eine seiner Nieren verkauft hatte, um sich ein iPhone und ein iPad zu kaufen. Ich fragte die Studenten, was sie von diesem Fall hielten. In der anschließenden Diskussion vertraten viele von ihnen die libertäre Sicht. Wenn der Teenager ohne Druck oder Zwang freiwillig entschieden hat, seine Nieren zu verkaufen, dann sollte er das Recht dazu haben. Andere widersprachen und meinten, es sei unfair, dass die Reichen ihr Leben verlängern können, indem sie Nieren von den Armen kaufen. Aus den hinteren Reihen des Saals erwierte ein Student, dass Reichen, da sie sich ihr Vermögen erarbeitet hätten, Anerkennung zustehe und sie es deshalb verdient hätten, länger zu leben. Diese unverfrorene Anwendung des meritokratischen Denkens machte mich sprachlos. Erst im Nachhinein wurde mir klar, dass dieses Denken moralisch dem Glauben des Wohlstandsevangeliums verwandt ist, wonach Gesundheit und Wohlstand Zeichen für Gottes Gunst sind. Der chinesische Student, der es zum Ausdruck brachte, war wahrscheinlich nicht von puritanischer Ethik oder providenziellen Traditionen durchdrungen. Doch er und seine Komplitoren waren während Chinas Hinwendung zur Marktgesellschaft erwachsen geworden.
Ja, das fand ich auch schockierend zu lesen. Aber das sind diese Ein-Kind-Politik-Folgen, wenn alle nur noch in Konkurrenz zueinander aufwachsen und dann halt irgendwann da in der Welt vorstellig werden und anfangen, darüber zu sprechen, was ihnen in den letzten 20 Jahren in China mitgegeben wurde. Das ist ja auch diese Ethik des Könnens, auf die er da noch mal ganz spezifisch eingeht. Da muss ich auch wieder denken, systemtheoretisch ist das auch wieder. Diese radikale handlungstheoretische Sichtweise ist wirklich verdächtig eigentlich. Aber es ist eben unsere Gänge Ideologie. Und er macht ja dann auch noch einen Ausflug zu health and wealth. Also wer wohlhabend ist, ist ja auch meistens gesünder. Und diese ganze amerikanische Gesundheitsvorsorge- Versorgungsdiskussion gewinnt hier natürlich auch noch mal so eine neue Perspektive. Er zitiert den Whole Foods Gründer 2009, John McKay, der während der Obamacare-Debatte publizistisch tätig wird und dann einfach sagt, ja wieso? Also die gesundheitlichen Probleme, die Menschen so haben, sind doch selbst verschuldet. Wieso soll denn jetzt die Allgemeinheit, wieso soll ich jetzt für irgendwen anderen die gesundheitlichen Probleme finanziell schultern und so weiter? Und da steckt eben all das so drin. Wer es nicht kann, wer es nicht verdient hat, wer es sich nicht aus eigener Leistung schafft, der verdient eben einfach keine Gesundheit. Klar, alle Zivilisationskrankheiten und das Übergewicht kann man halt so runterbrechen und einfach sagen, aber es sind eben da auch wieder die äußeren Umstände, die einfach Menschen dazu verleiten, so zu leben, wie sie leben. Und am Ende braucht man sie eben doch. Das hat ja dann Schiritz auch wieder bei Olaf Scholz. Dieses starke Moment oder diese starke Argumentation der Arbeitsteilung. Menschen verdienen weniger, wenn sie Pfleger sind, statt Ärzte oder wenn sie, keine Ahnung, den Müll abholen, statt in irgendwelchen Hochhäusern irgendwas am Telefon zu erklären. Also ein typisches Büroangestellten-Dasein. Aber das heißt ja noch lange nicht, nur dass, weil das mit dem Müll könnte ja jeder machen, dass durch Austauschbarkeit der Preis für diese Arbeit relativ gering ist, dass es deswegen nicht erledigt werden kann. Es muss ja trotzdem erledigt werden. Und es ist ja viel wichtiger. Der gesellschaftliche Beitrag ist ja enorm an der Stelle. Nur der Arbeitsmarkt ist halt fluktual, also weiß ich nicht, was ich meine. Also hier einfach flexibler. Man kann einfach Leute schneller anlernen und so. Kann diese Arbeit dann in dem Sinne leichter erledigt machen. Deswegen ist der Preis irgendwie geringer und deswegen die Wertschätzung, aber eben nicht die Bedeutung.
Und weil das BIP dann Maßstab von allem ist, das ist ja auch etwas, wogegen er sich wendet. Denn selbstverständlich, wenn man nur aufs BIP schielt, dann kann man sagen, ist Kehrarbeit nicht so viel wert. Denn es bringt keinen BIP-Nutzen, wenn man 90-Jährige pflegt. Die werden ja nicht danach aus dem Bett aufspringen und dann nochmal ein Auto montieren oder sogar eins erfinden. Nein, die werden gepflegt und irgendwann sterben sie. Und deswegen dienen die nicht dem BIP. Und deswegen ist diese Kehrarbeit auch sehr schlecht bezahlt. Wenn man sagt, wir richten den Preis der Arbeit nur auf das aus, was es dem BIP bringt. Denn dass es irgendetwas mit Verdienst zu tun hat, mit ja, übernimmt so viel Verantwortung oder so, das wird ja dann sehr schnell fraglich bei Hedgefonds-Managern. Da wird dann gesagt, na ja, aber die haben ja die Verantwortung für das ganze Geld, das sie verwalten. Aber das haben sie natürlich nicht. Und man weiß, dass jeder Kindergärtner mehr Verantwortung gerade übernimmt, wenn der Ausflug in dem Zoo stattfindet und man muss alle Kinder über die Straße bringen. Dann weiß man, dass das viel verantwortungsvoller ist, als wenn da jetzt jemand mit irgendwelchen Fonds hin und her managt. Und das Erstaunliche ist, es gibt ja nicht nur ein Kapitel, das sich zu dem Calvinismus äußert, sondern auch eines, das sich mit Rawls und Hayek auseinandersetzt. Und auch das ist ja sehr erstaunlich, dass Hayek zwar überhaupt nicht auf so eine Gemeinwohlökonomie oder so was aus ist, aber dass auch er ganz klar sagt, nee, verdienst, also das, was man verdient, das hat nichts mit der wirklichen Leistung in dem Sinne zu tun. Oder man hat es im moralischen Sinne verdient. Das lehnt Hayek ab und ist da auch ganz ehrlich, also er ist nicht verlogen, wie das bei der FDP zu finden ist, sondern denen müsste man jetzt eigentlich mal sagen, liest bei Hayek wenigstens mal nach. Der hat nicht diese eigenartige Ideologie. Und ich habe dann selbst bei Hayek mal nachgeschaut, und zwar in dem Buch Recht, Gesetz und Freiheit. Da gibt es diese erstaunliche Passage, in der es heißt, es ist daher ein echtes Dilemma, wie sehr wir in jungen Menschen den Glauben bestärken sollten, dass sie, wenn sie sich wirklich bemühen, Erfolg haben werden. Oder, ob wir eher betonen sollten, dass unweigerlich manche, die ihn nicht verdienen, Erfolg haben werden, und andere, die ihn verdienen würden, keinen. Ob wir die Ansichten jener Gruppe sich durchsetzen lassen, sollten in denen übermäßiges Vertrauen in die angemessene Entlohnung der Fähigkeiten und Einsatzfreudigen herrscht und die infolgedessen vieles tun werden, was den Übrigen zugute kommt, und ob ohne solche, teils irrige Vorstellungen, die große Masse, tatsächliche Entlohnungsunterschiede dulden wird, die nur teilweise auf Leistung, aber teilweise rein auf Glück beruhen. Also selbst Hayek spekuliert hier ganz offen, naja, sollten wir vielleicht aber diese Leistungsideologie noch aufrechterhalten, denn was ist eigentlich, wenn wir alle darüber nachdenken, dass das gar nicht so ist? Und das macht Sandel, er denkt darüber nach.
Genau, ich muss auch gerade, als du von den Kindern sprachst, die man über die Straße bringen muss, Kinder sind ja eigentlich heute auch so kulmulierte, wie auch immer, Geldsäcke. Also ein achtjähriges Kind ist ja eine echte Investition für jeden, der für das Verantwortung trägt.
Sagt Gary S. Becker auch, der neoliberale.
Also man kann es...
Investitionen und sehr risikobehaftete.
Ich denke gerade, wir haben ja Adam Toos gelesen und er hat ja immer runtergebrochen. Jeder einzelne Todesfall kostet so und so viel. Und wir waren ja beeindruckt von diesen Zahlen, die da genannt werden. Also wenn ein Prozent der Bevölkerung weg ist, dann hat er gleich in 10 Billionen oder so gedacht. Das ist dann ein echten... Und ich finde es so wahnsinnig interessant, dass wir auf der einen Seite jetzt gerade unter so einer Rentnerpublik leiden, weil wir immer glauben, wir müssten aber künftig ganz schön viele Alte durchbringen. Und dafür gibt es ja nur noch sehr viel weniger. Also dieser Faktor des alten Quotienten wird ja von heute 35 auf 65 steigen. Also pro 100 Menschen, die arbeiten, gibt es nicht nur 35 zu versorgender Alte, sondern 65. Das ist also viel. Das sind 95 Prozent, 90 Prozent mehr. Fast eine Verdopplung. Nur, wenn wir uns die Sachlage angucken, das ist nicht der höchste Stand, den Deutschland jemals hatte bei der allgemeinen Versorgungslage. Nur diesmal sind es halt die Alten, von denen du eben schon gesagt hast, BIP-mäßig kommt da wenig bei rum am Ende. Die springen nicht irgendwann aus dem Bett und sind wieder geheilt von ihrem Alter. Und wir hatten vor 40 Jahren durch den Baby-Boom einen sehr viel höheren Anteil an Zuversorgenden als heute. Nur waren es eben die Kinder. Wir haben es also irgendwie geschultert und wir wussten, und schon die Vorfreude hat ausgereicht, um dieses enorme Wirtschaftswachstum auszulösen. Da sind nämlich bald sehr viele Kinder da einfach. Und wir bereiten schon mal alles vor. Wir machen es schon mal für die toll. Und in deren Sicht fragt man sich heute so ein bisschen, naja, aber können wir nicht mit den Alten irgendwie so umgehen, wie wir es vorher mit den Kindern gemacht haben? Klar, die stehen nur als Konsumenten in der Volkswirtschaft zur Verfügung, aber damit kann man doch arbeiten. Konnten wir doch schon mal. Wieso kriegen wir das nicht wieder hin? Auf der anderen Seite Menschen, die alt sind und dann zu versorgen, die sind ja nicht sofort gebrechlich. Die leben ja heute noch viel länger. Und ich war dann wieder tief beeindruckt. In den Niederlanden ist die Kalkulation gerade so, dass man, wenn man ins Rentenalter kommt, 101% der durchschnittlichen vorigen Lohnzahlung bekommt. Also mehr. Kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen. Man wird Rentner und bekommt plötzlich mehr. Weil 70% läuft über Betriebsrenten und die Betriebsrenten waren verpflichtend. Und die Unternehmen mussten sich halt wirklich Gedanken machen, wie sie teile ihrer Produktivität um Münzen in Geld für die eigenen Mitarbeiter später. Sodass die dann auch wieder im Alter als Konsumenten entsprechend mehr für alle Unternehmen zur Verfügung stehen. Und in Deutschland ist diese Quote eben nicht 101%, sondern 55%. Das heißt, bei uns fallen am Ende einfach die Alten raus und sind ab dem Tag des Rentenalters Verlierer. Sie werden kämpfen müssen um ihre Versorgung, um ihre Aufmerksamkeit, um alles Mögliche. Und wir haben hier alle Chancen verspielt, Whoopies aus ihnen zu machen. Und diesen Begriff des Whoopies, würde ich gerne sehen, den jeder kennt, das ist der Well of all the people. Also alte Menschen, denen es gut geht. Die irgendwie feststellen, oh Mann, Arbeit ist Würde. Jetzt habe ich keine Arbeit mehr. Wo sind eigentlich meine Würde? Ich gehe einfach in den Kindergarten, lese vor. Ich gehe einfach zu den Pfadfindern und helfe mit. Ich mache einfach dieses und jenes. Weil ich bin ja noch fit und ich habe das Geld. Ich kann mir einen Fahrschein kaufen. So, und das ist in Deutschland flächendeckend den Menschen einfach verwehrt. Wir haben jetzt zehn Jahre lang Rentner, die mit gebrochenen Erwerbsbiografien, lauter Lücken, die erste Akademikerschwemme, die erst mit 35 angefangen hat zu arbeiten, alles Herausforderungen, die wir gar nicht kennen. Und anstatt die einfach aufzufangen, gut, dass ihr da seid, politisch entschieden, ist es einfach, jeder von euch kriegt 1500 Rente. Nö, ist nicht. Die Durchschnittsrente in Deutschland liegt bei 1000 Euro. Die Hälfte bekommt weniger als 1000 Euro. In Österreich sind die Renten im Schnitt um 800 Euro höher. Und die Niederländer, für die macht das gar keinen Unterschied, ob sie arbeiten oder nicht. Die sind einfach versorgt. So, und in Deutschland liefern wir gerade alle so einem Verliererdasein aus, wie der Sandel hier beklagt. Und das ist wirklich dramatisch. Und jetzt, wo ich das Buch gelesen habe, muss ich natürlich einen Rentnerpublic auch noch mal drüber schreiben. Und ich habe selbst ein bisschen Angst davor, das auszuformulieren. Das ist wirklich dramatisch.
Und das ist so augenöffnend hier. Wir müssen auch über einen anderen Aspekt sprechen. Denn es ist ja auch ein Buch, das nochmal so ein bisschen erklärt, wie konnte das mit Trump passieren? Du hattest es schon angedeutet und man denkt zunächst, oh Gott, brauche ich jetzt noch eine Erklärung. Aber ich finde dann diese besonders plausibel. Er sagt, aus dieser meritokratischen Ideologie heraus ergibt sich ja dann nicht nur für sich selbst, dass man es verdient zu haben scheint, sondern so etwas wie Stolz formt sich und ein Überlegenheitsgestus. Der ist dann bei jenen vertreten, die es geschafft haben, die diese tollen Unis besucht haben, die die entsprechenden Gehälter kassieren. Und diese haben dann mitunter, und da sind wir schon ein bisschen bei einer Wagenknecht-Diagnose, aber doch auf eine sehr viel fundiertere Weise, dass wir es dann mit Leuten zu tun haben, die fast ihre eigene Sprache entwickeln, also die Begrifflichkeiten verwenden, die die anderen Leute eher nicht verstehen. Oder sie verwenden sie aus Gründen der Distinktion, um sich abzusetzen von diesen Leuten. Hinzu kommt auch, dass diese Elite sich die ganze Zeit selbst erklärt nochmal, wie großartig sie ist. Und was dann auch ganz häufig in dieser Unterscheidung kommt, die die Elite macht und die dann auch die Politiker machen, auch da hat er sich ja wieder Reden angesehen, ist intelligent und dumm. Da ist die Unterscheidung. Und wer jetzt nicht faktenbasiert argumentieren will, wer jetzt die Studien nicht rezipiert hat, wer sich nicht in dieser Form ausdrückt, der ist dumm. Was machen wir eigentlich mit dem Dummen? Wie kommen wir denn damit klar? Und die Elite, die verständigt sich dann über einen entsprechenden Fachdiskurs. Und das ist etwas, was er dann auch bei Obama zitiert. Obama, da heißt es, betrachtete es als den besten Weg, den verdrehten politischen Prozess Amerikas zu heilen. Die Herausforderung bestand nicht darin, die gewaltige Konzentration wirtschaftlicher Macht aufzubrechen, die den politischen Prozess niederdrückte oder darin in der Öffentlichkeit einen geschärften Sinn für das Gemeinwohl zu wicken. Es ging darum, bessere und genauere Informationen zu liefern. Zitat, ich habe wirklich vor, das zu verwirklichen, denn ich bin ein großer Anhänger von Vernunft, Fakten, Evidenz, von Wissenschaft und Feedback, sagte er zu seinem Publikum bei Google. Ich möchte im Weißen Haus dieses Gespür dafür erneuern, dass Entscheidungen auf Fakten beruhen sollten. Das ist dann das, was Sandel die technokratische Ideologie nennt, dass man damit allen anderen sagt, die eine gegenteilige Position haben, das sind nicht die Fakten, du bist dumm, du gehörst nicht zu uns Intelligenten. Dass das eine Spaltung in der Gesellschaft hervorruft, die sich ökonomisch ausdrückt, die sich aber auch damit ausdrückt, dass all jene, die an diesem Fakten-Diskurs nicht teilnehmen oder teilnehmen wollen, ausgeschlossen werden.
Oder, das kennen wir ja von Merkel, sie hat ja diese Nudging-Psychologenstellen damals ausgeschrieben. Bei Obama ist es einfach Incentivizing. Also es wird so ein Ziel formuliert, und dann ist das Handeln aber ein bisschen unklar. Leadership bedeutet, das Volk soll einfach vertrauen. Die Expertise der Regierung wird schon ausreichen. Und dann soll das Volk halt instinkt gehandelt einfach mitziehen.
Und wenn es es dann nicht tut, dann ist man ganz verwirrt. Dann sagt man, das ist ja... Und am Ende steht auch noch mal so eine lästige Wahl an. Das möchte man dann auch eigentlich nicht.
Genau, aber man wird so aktiviert. Man weiß, man muss jetzt irgendwie handeln. Aber es gibt ja diesen Alarmismus. Man weiß, irgendwas ist jetzt zu tun, aber man weiß nicht was. Dann ist Eile geboten und nachträglich weiß man dann, alles war falsch. Und da kann man ja echt nochmal, weil sie es wirklich anbietet, die Regierungserklärung von Gerhard Schröder damals zitieren. Denn da steckt genau diese Aktivierung, dieser Alarmismus steckt da einfach drin. Schröder damals im Bundestag. Und Sandel zitiert das eben. Und das finde ich so Wahnsinn, wenn so deutsche Regierungserklärungen in solchen Texten zitiert werden. Also mit diesen Maßnahmen machen wir unseren Sozialstaat auch gegen die Stürme der Globalisierung wetterfest. Wir werden dabei in jeder Hinsicht ein Mehr an Verantwortung brauchen. Mehr Eigenverantwortung jedes Einzelnen und mehr gemeinsame Verantwortung für die Chancen unserer Kinder. Sozial heißt für mich, jeder hat gleiche Chancen. Das heißt aber auch, jeder hat die Pflicht, seine Chancen zu nutzen. Das heute zu lesen ist so Wahnsinn. Das ist so die Brandbombe, die genauso formuliert werden muss, um größtmöglichen Schaden anzurichten. Inklusive aller politischen Entscheidungen, die seitdem getroffen wurden und Folgen, die wir heute kennen. Das ist einfach ganz schlimm. Hier noch mal so erinnert zu werden an so deutsches Regierungshandeln.
Aber sehr gut, dass es so klar geschieht und dass es auch so wunderbar immer wieder historisch eingeordnet wird in diese Entwicklung, die die amerikanische Gesellschaft genommen hat. Denn es war ja eine Zeit lang so eine Erbaristokratie, die sich gebildet hatte an den Universitäten. Und dann kommt da jemand, der sagt, das ist eigentlich gar nicht gut. Man müsste diese Universitäten doch komplett reformieren, dass also die wirklichen Leistungsträger es schaffen. Und man hat eigentlich, so schreibt es dann Sandel, aus der Erbaristokratie eine Leistungsaristokratie gemacht. Was aber auch wiederum bedeutet, dass die, die ökonomisch schon Erfolg haben, dann ihren Kindern diesen Erfolg auch verschaffen können. Nicht nur durch Formen der Korruption, sondern auch durch Nachhilfen, durch lauter Hilfestellungen, die man nun mal hat, wenn man sehr reich ist. Und dass es sich überhaupt nicht gezeigt hat, dass da etwas entsteht. Aber genau das wird auch generell in Frage gestellt. Ist es überhaupt so, dass man eine bessere Gesellschaft hat, wenn man einfach nur auf Chancengleichheit setzt und dann diese Verpflichtung mit dazu nimmt, wie Schröder das getan hat? Und da bezieht er sicher auf einen Autor, den ich noch überhaupt nicht kannte, der mir bislang neu war, der aber schon das sehr früh angesprochen hat, nämlich Michael Young. Und Michael Young hat ja ein Buch geschrieben, das sich gegen diese Idee der Leistungsgesellschaft richtet, weil er sagt, na ja, wenn alle dann in einer absolut chancengleichen Gesellschaft agieren würden, dann hätten wir nicht einen einzigen Verlierer weniger, sondern das System wäre immer noch eines, das einige wenige Gewinner produziert, und der Rest sind Verlierer. Das mag dann vielleicht diverser sein, und die mögen vielleicht dann aus unterschiedlichen ökonomischen Schichten stammen. Aber wir haben es nicht dann mit einer wirklich freien Gesellschaft zu tun, mit einer Gesellschaft der Gleichheit und auch nicht mit einer solidarischen Gesellschaft. Also er malt das wirklich auf. Was bedeutet das denn eigentlich, wenn ich in einer Leistungsgesellschaft lebe und es nicht geschafft habe, aber es hätte schaffen können und mich hat kein Vorurteil oder irgendetwas daran behindert? Dann heißt das wirklich nur noch, ich bin schuld. Und das wiederum bedeutet dann, dass man das entweder auf sich projiziert und sehr unglücklich wird. Mental Health spielt da eine große Rolle, die Suizidrate ist eklatant gestiegen in den USA. Der Tod aus Verzweiflung, so nennt er das, im Übrigen ganz stark bei weißen Männern. Das ist ja etwas, was man auch nicht allzu häufig liest. Oder es führt dann dazu, dass man das nicht gegen sich selbst richtet, sondern eben gegen andere. Und das sind dann wahlweise Flüchtlinge, Chinesen, was auch immer. Und das finde ich sehr interessant, dass er nochmal auf so einen älteren Text hier eingeht und dass es tatsächlich so war, dass er dann beschreibt, bevor es diese Meritokratie gibt und die Aufstiegschancen sehr schlecht waren für Arbeiter, sondern man war Arbeiter und als Sohn eines Arbeiters blieb man Arbeiter. Welchen Effekt hatte das eigentlich? Und Michael Young schreibt da, der Arbeiter sagte sich, hier bin ich ein Arbeiter. Warum bin ich denn Arbeiter? Tauge ich denn zu nichts anderem? Aber klar, hätte ich nur die richtige Chance gehabt, ich hätte es der Welt schon gezeigt. Arzt hätte ich werden können oder Bierbrauer oder Minister. Warum nicht? Ich hätte alles fertiggebracht, aber ich hatte nie die richtige Gelegenheit, also bin ich halt Arbeiter. Aber denken Sie ja nicht, dass ich im Grunde schlechter wäre als jemand anderes. Das heißt, wenn man noch keine Chancengleichheit hat, dann hat man quasi eine Entschuldigung für seine Position, weil man sagen kann, die Umstände gestatten ist mir ja nicht. Aber wenn ich sage, jeder kann es jetzt schaffen, Schröder hat es gesagt und es ist meine Pflicht, dann heißt das, wie du bist Arbeiter. Warum bist du eigentlich kein Minister? Bist du etwa dumm? Das ist genau das, was dann zu einer Politik des Populismus führt, was dazu führt, dass Leute sehr verzweifelt sind und vielleicht sogar den Tod wählen.
Am Ende des Buches, das können wir ja kurz machen, ist es wieder ein ganz amerikanischer Text, der sich um den Ausleseapparat der Universitäten kümmert. Und auch mit der Erinnerung, dass der Harvard-Präsident James Conant 1940 ein meritokratisches Unisystem einführen wollte, das soziale Mobilität wieder zulässt, mit entsprechenden Funktionsprinzipien wie Stimpenien usw. Das allerdings super korrumpiert alles heute. Entweder es gibt diese Sporttracks, wo man sich einkaufen kann, oder dieser ganze SAT-Kram, wo er auch immer darauf hinweist. Also SAT-Vorbereitungskurse, Milliarden-Business. Einzelne Eltern zahlen bis zu 1.000 Dollar pro Stunde für Nachhilfe ihrer Kinder. Also das ist einfach der totale Wahnsinn, wie festgezurrt das da immer wieder ist. Er kommt natürlich klar auf dieses Plädoyer. Wir haben es ja auch bei Blakely gelesen. Diese ganze Financialisierung der Welt ist halt ein wirkliches Problem. Wir bräuchten im Grunde ein neues Steuersystem. Eins, das auf Verteilung und mit Anerkennung nochmal anders umgeht. Steuern wirklich als Steuern zu verwenden, so wie wir es bei MMT auch schon ein bisschen angelegt haben.
Ja, es ist eine MMT-Position darin. Und ich finde eine Idee, auch eine, die glaube ich jetzt, wenn uns Leute, die in der Politik tätig sind, zuhören, oder Aktivisten, die das vielleicht stark machen könnten, er sagt, warum gibt es eigentlich diese hohen Steuern auf Arbeit? Wir haben das ja auch in Deutschland. Wer ein Gehalt bekommt, muss das höher versteuern, als wenn er an der Börse mit Bitcoin rumspekuliert. Das ist ja absurd.
Danke, Schröder. Vorher war das ja anders.
Genau. Und hier wird es umgedreht und da sagt er sogar, brauchen wir überhaupt Steuern auf Arbeit? Könnten wir nicht tatsächlich auf Spekulation, auf Renditen, könnten wir nicht da richtig hohe Steuern erheben? Und da würde ich auch sagen, da ist ein positiv populistisches Moment drin, dass man sagt, nee, arbeiten wollen wir nicht mehr so stark besteuern. Und es war ganz interessant, ich war ja mal in dieser Sendung 13 Fragen zur Erbschaftssteuer und das Gegenteam, die also gegen eine Erbschaftssteuer waren, die schlugen ja dann vor, naja, man könnte, nee, die Erbschaftssteuer, die darf auf keinen Fall erhöht werden und so was darf nicht sein. Und dann sagten die tatsächlich, aber man könnte ja die Unternehmenssteuern vielleicht erhöhen. Wo ich dann noch sagte, ja, aber da wird ja tatsächlich vielleicht noch von jemandem, der noch nichts ererbt hat, gerade was erarbeitet. Und der soll dann stärker besteuert werden, bevor man auch nur ein Prozent die Erbschaftssteuer anhebe. Also das ist diese Ideologie, die ganz fest verankert ist. Und dazu einfach mal zu sagen, nee, man könnte vielleicht ja auch die Arbeit gar nicht besteuern oder viel geringer besteuern und dafür woanders das richtig hochsetzen. Dafür gäbe es ja Mehrheiten. Denn mag sein, dass ein paar Leute jetzt ihr Online-Proker-Depot haben. Aber das fällt ja nicht ins Gewicht gegen das, was sie versteuern müssen, wenn sie arbeiten. Finde ich eine tolle Idee. Und die zweite Idee, die man gleich mitnehmen kann und vielleicht in Politik umdenken kann, ist, dass er sagt, muss eigentlich die Universität das Bildungsmonopol innehaben? Und ich glaube, das können wir ganz klar mit Nein beantworten. Er sagt, Bibliotheken sind eigentlich die großen demokratischen Orte. Da sitzt Arm und Reich und alle sitzen im Lesesaal und lesen. Wir können das auch ins Digitale übertragen. Macht er leider nicht, dass man sagen kann, im Internet sind diese Zugänge da. Und ich sehe ja auch bei ganz vielen Leuten, es gibt einen Hang, sich mit z.B. Naturwissenschaften oder Geisteswissenschaften auseinanderzusetzen, ohne dass man irgendwie damit im Studium Berührung hatte oder ohne dass man vielleicht studiert hat. D.h., da ist eigentlich ein Ort zu schaffen oder es sind Orte zu schaffen für öffentliche Bildung. Bibliotheken, da ist noch viel zu tun, oder die müssten umstrukturiert werden. Aber vielleicht auch andere digitale öffentliche Orte, weil die dieses Gemeinwohl empfinden auch, dass es braucht, um sich als Gesellschaft zu verstehen, wieder zu ermöglichen.
Genau, diese große Entfrachtung, Entschlackung der Arbeit steckt da so drin. Er hat ja zwischendurch auch diese Idee, kann man nicht noch mal über Gesellschaft nachdenken, bei der sich erst mal alle auf das System verständigen und danach die Plätze einnehmen. Sodass man nicht von Anfang an, also meine Gesellschaft, wie du es dann sagst, wenn ich was zu vererben habe, sieht meine Gesellschaft in der Wunschvorstellung natürlich ganz anders aus, als jemand, der irgendwie sein Unternehmen gründen will und so weiter. Also in der sich das Buch läuft sehr konstruktiv aus am Ende. Also so wird diesen ganzen Ideenapparat echt koppelt an politische Fehlentscheidungen. Auch für uns Deutsche super interessant zu lesen, weil er auch unsere nennt einfach und kennt, kann man am Ende sehr viel. Also für Aktivisten würde ich sagen, steckt da viel in dem Buch hinten raus. Aber es ist auch grundsätzlich einfach mal wohltuend, einfach zu lesen. Und das ist ja, ehrlich gesagt, immer so ein bisschen das Ziel von dem Text, dass man erst mal auf Verständnis trifft. Von Leuten, die gar nicht wussten, dass es da noch so viel zu erzählen und zu verstehen gibt, aber was dann irgendwie so Sinn ergibt. Und in deren Sicht war das einfach ein sehr gewinnbringendes Buch. Also falls ihr euch, das haben wir jetzt häufiger so als Ansage, ich bin ja immer wieder überrascht, dass Menschen, die uns zuhören, dann doch diese Bücher, die wir besprechen, sehr häufig dann kaufen. In dem Fall würde ich sagen, ja, warum nicht? Also dieses zweite Kapitel vor allem, das kann nicht nur ein Spateninteresse zum Neokalvinismus von mir sein, weil ich das als Begriff vor 15 Jahren oder so mal gehört habe, sondern das ist so ein allgemein gültiger Text.
Ja, und auch die Auseinandersetzung mit Rawls und Hayek lohnt sich sehr nachzuvollziehen. Und dann auch das, was konkret vorgeschlagen wird und noch mal sehr viele Zahlen, die man liest, die einem einfach sagen, das ist ja unglaublich. Im Senat in den USA sind 100% mit akademischem Abschluss. In Deutschland gibt es im Bundestag ein oder zwei Menschen mit Hauptschulabschluss. Also das sind auch noch mal Zahlen, die einem sehr zu denken geben.
Ja, also der vorletzte Bundestag hatte sechs Mitglieder mit einem naturwissenschaftlich-technisch beruflichen Hintergrund. Alles andere war irgendwas anderes an der Ansicht. Die Lage ist dramatisch. Und Gott sei Dank liest Olaf Scholz die richtigen Bücher.
Ja, möge es auch immer dann richtige Politik zur richtigen Politik führen. Wir werden sehen. Michael Sandel hat ein herausragendes, ein glänzendes Buch geschrieben über die Tyrannei der Leistungsgesellschaft. Jeder bekommt doch am Ende, was er verdient, wenn er sich nur ordentlich anstrengt. Das sagt einem vielleicht die Intuition. Aber dieses Buch lehrt uns, kontraintuitiv zu denken. Es ist augenöffnend und es leitet sich sehr viel Aktivismus und kluge Politik davon ab.
Und manchmal leidet man so sehr an seinem eigenen Leben, dass Menschen von außen kommen und sagen, durchstöber doch nochmal deine Kindheit. Das droht uns hier nicht. Und das muss man auch nicht zwingend machen. Aber viele sind der Meinung, sie leben ein Leben ohne Gott. Die Religion ist abgeschlossen, sie brauchen das nicht. Wir haben doch jetzt Wissenschaft. Nein, es ist so viel Aufklärungsbedarf da, um die aktuelle Politik zu verstehen. Und selten eigentlich nie haben wir ein Buch gehabt, in dem ein Autor sich diese Aufgabe stellte, diese Aufklärungsarbeit und ihr wirklich nachkam.
Wir kommen zu großer Literatur aus Brasilien. Es ist der erste ins Deutsche übersetzte Roman von Tatiana Salem-Levy, die aber schon einige Bücher publiziert hat. Dieser Roman heißt Vista Chinesa, hat aber nichts mit China in dem Sinne zu tun, sondern es ist der Ort, an dem das alles passiert. Eine Frau, Anfang 30, ist Architektin, ist involviert in die Olympischen Spiele, in die Vorbereitung. Sie soll da einen großen Golfplatz gestalten. Und es gibt diese Aufbruchsstimmung in Brasilien. Man denkt, jetzt könnte doch vielleicht auch der Weg in eine offenere Gesellschaft funktionieren. Und diese junge Frau hat einen wichtigen Termin, einen Geschäftstermin, am Nachmittag. Und vorher sagt sie sich, ich gehe mal noch eine Runde joggen. Zwar haben mir immer mal wieder Freunde, Bekannte oder auch ihr Mann gesagt, passen ein bisschen auf, es ist alles auch immer gefährlich in unserer Gesellschaft hier. Aber naja, sie geht trotzdem natürlich joggen. Und sie ist auch an eigentlich ganz normalen öffentlichen Orten unterwegs. Und plötzlich wird diese Frau in den Regenwald hineingezogen. Sie läuft da also her und dann taucht jemand auf, zieht sie in diesen Regenwald immer weiter ins Dickicht hinein und vergewaltigt sie dort brutal. Der Text geht damit so um, dass uns das geschildert wird in einem fast expressionistischen Sinne, dass man so Schlaglichter nur zu lesen bekommt. Das Auge, die Nase, es stinkt irgendwie, Schweiß, es ist Gewalt, es sind Striemen plötzlich auf meinem Körper. Und dann taucht aber diese Vergewaltigung immer wieder in diesem gerade mal 125-seitigen Text auf. Und es geht darum, wie diese Vergewaltigung sich auf ihrem Körper bemerkbar macht, sich dort einschreibt. Ich glaube, hier kann man diese Formulierung mal verwenden, wie sie damit umgeht, die Protagonistin, wie sie versucht, zu einer Normalität zu kommen, wie sie versucht, den Täter zu finden, wie sie immer wieder von der Polizei Verdächtige vorgeführt bekommt. Die schaut sie sich an und sagt, ja, das könnte er sein. Und manchmal denkt sie sich, das muss er sein. Ich muss jetzt jemanden verdächtigen und ich muss jetzt sagen, das war der Täter, damit ich selbst abschließen kann. Und dann im nächsten Moment zu sagen, nee, das geht nicht. Ich kann nicht jetzt jemand anders dafür verantwortlich machen, der es nicht war, nur damit ich meine Geschichte abschließen kann. Und irgendwann beschließt sie dann auch nicht mehr weiter mit der Polizei zusammenzuarbeiten, weil sie ihr Leben leben will. Und irgendwann gibt es dann auch Kinder. Und an diese Kinder ist dieses Buch gerichtet, wenn man so möchte. Denn es ist ein Brief, den diese Frau Jahre später ihren Kindern schreibt, damit die Kinder, wenn sie einmal erwachsen sind, ihr lesen können. Diese Frau gibt es wirklich. Sie ist die Freundin, eine gute Freundin der Autorin. Und so ist dieses Buch entstanden mit langen Gesprächen. Aber dann hat eine enorme Literarisierung stattgefunden. Das heißt, es geht jetzt hier nicht um einen Tatsachenbericht. Also das ist nicht das, was man vorlegen kann der Polizei, sondern es geht wirklich um Literatur. Und ich habe ja eben gesagt, man spürt den eigenen Körper anders. Und es gibt ja in den 60er-, 70er-Jahren in der feministischen Literaturwissenschaft diese Debatte, ob es ein weibliches Schreiben gibt oder nicht. Das ist unbeantwortet geblieben. Ich bin da auch sehr skeptisch, dass man so etwas fixieren kann. Ich kann aber für diese Literatur, die ich hier gelesen habe, zumindest sagen, dass sie eine Literatur ist, die versucht, das Körperliche erfahrbar zu machen. Und zwar nicht nur das Körperliche der Vergewaltigung, sondern es gibt auch Momente der Ekstase, der Lust und des Sexes. Es gibt aber auch etwas, was wir Männer am allerwenigsten körperlich direkt nachvollziehen können, nämlich das Gefühl der Schwangerschaft und der Mutterschaft. Und das ist etwas, was diese Literatur versucht zu beschreiben, dass man also in einen anderen Körper schlüpfen kann durch das Lesen. Und das ist etwas, was mich wirklich tief beeindruckt hat, mit welch einer Sprachwucht das geschieht. Und ich will nur eine einzige Passage daraus lesen, weil es um so vieles geht. Hier auch wieder um den Körper, aber auch um grundsätzliche Fragen der Mutterschaft, grundsätzliche Frage des Vererbens. Und zwar heißt es da, Antonia, so heißt die kleine Tochter, ist gerade in der Warum-Phase. Kürzlich ist eine Freundin in der Kita traurig gewesen, der Hund war gestorben. Antonia wollte wissen, was sterben bedeutet. Ich habe es ihr mehr oder weniger erklärt. Den Tod richtig erklären geht bei einem dreijährigen Kind nicht. Und am Schluss hat sie mich gefragt, ob auch ich irgendwann sterben werde. Und als ich das bejahte, sagte sie, warum, Mama? Ich war so gerührt, wir haben uns fest umarmt, eine solche Zärtlichkeit, eine unglaubliche Liebe, die Vorstellung, dass sie die Fortsetzung von mir ist, so wie ich die Fortsetzung meiner Mutter bin, dass wir uns in bestimmten Augenblicken vermischen, diese Synthese aus Vergangenheit gegenwart Zukunft sind, die in uns dreien enthalten ist, ein einziger Mensch. Ich war so berauscht, von diesem Gefühl war richtig glücklich, das war ein glücklicher Augenblick, bis mir klar wurde, wir können uns nicht vermischen. Wir können nicht der gleiche Mensch sein, nicht mal annähernd der gleiche Mensch sein. Ich möchte nicht, dass meine Geschichte zur Geschichte meiner Tochter wird, dass mein Körper zum Körper meiner Tochter wird. Da wurde dieses leichte, heitere Glück verdrängt von der Angst, der Beklemmung, der Schuld. Bei einer Mutter ist alles immer nur Schuld. Ich begann, mich schuldig zu fühlen, weil ich diesen kaputten Körper hatte, weil ich dieses Problem bis heute nicht gelöst hatte, weil ich, selbst wenn ich meine Tochter im Arm halte, an diesen Dienstag denke. Also, dem Dienstag, dem diese Vergewaltigung geschah. Es ist ein fulminantes Stück Literatur. Ich hoffe, dass dieser Roman erfolgreich wird. Und ich hoffe, es vor allem auch, damit mehr von dieser Autorin übersetzt wird, denn ich würde gerne mehr lesen. Also, eine absolute Empfehlung.
Sehr gut. Ich glaube natürlich an diese Art der Vermischung. Das wäre natürlich harte Kost. Vielleicht lese ich aus diesen Gründen solche Bücher nicht, weil eben das dann so ausgetrieben wird. Aus Gründen, die da nachvollziehbar sind, wahrscheinlich oder sein sollten, die man aber nicht nachvollziehen möchte. Gut, schließen wir nochmal an Sandel und der Leistungsfähigkeit und der Gabel, die man dann von der Gesellschaft empfängt, je nachdem, wie man sich einbringt. Es ist ein Text vom August 2021, aber das spielt hier nicht zur Sache. Und er beginnt wie folgt mit Hinweisen auf, ja, da war so eine Mail und da stand drin, wir möchten ihnen 15 Millionen schenken, aber wir haben die erstmal ungeöffnet liegen lassen, weil solche Mail gibt es ja viele. Andere Mails, 20 Millionen Versprechen, ignoriert von einer Assistentin. Mit einer weiteren Mail ist jemand zum Anwalt gegangen, hat gefragt, kann man da irgendwas machen, was ist denn das? Ignorieren sie es einfach. Stellt sich raus, alle Mails sind echt und alle Geldgeschenke sollten einfach so ankommen, da wo auch die E-Mails ankamen. Man hätte nur die E-Mails lesen und sagen müssen, gerne hier ist unsere Kontonummer, zack das Geld wäre gekommen. Oder ist halt auch gekommen, nur dann eben verzögert. Das sind so diese Geschichten, wo einfach noch mal so eine kleine Zeitschleife drin steckte, wegen Verunsicherungen, Unsicherheit, Pi, auch immer. Hinter diesen E-Mails steckt das Team, das sich um MacKenzie Scotts Vermögen kümmert. MacKenzie Scott ist die Erbin, kann man nicht sagen, aber die Nutzenieserin der teuersten Scheidung der Geschichte, nämlich von Jeff Bezos, der damals reichster Mensch der Welt war und danach immer noch reichster Mensch der Welt war, obwohl er fast die Hälfte seines Vermögens, ungefähr 65 Milliarden an seine Frau abgab, die heute mit so einem Wissenschaftslehrer zusammenlebt. Und wie gesagt, ein Team beauftragt hat, Geld auszugeben. Das belief sich in den letzten zwölf Monaten von August angerechnet auf 8,6 Milliarden Dollar, also mehr als die Ford Foundation und die Gates Foundation an Geld verteilt hat. Wir haben es also mit einem gigantisch großen Berg zu tun, der einfach nur so per E-Mail verteilt wird und Bloomberg hat sich die Aufgabe gemacht, wir gehen dem mal nach, um wie viel Geld geht's, wer bekommt das, kriegt man irgendwas über sie raus, wie sie das so macht.
Interessiert sie sich vielleicht für Filmanalysen?
Zum Beispiel, das war ja eine Frage, die man sich stellen konnte. Also erstens, wie kriegst du ihre Aufmerksamkeit?
Bei uns ist auch einfach, bei der Filmanalyse ist ja auch einfach die Bankverbindung eingeblendet. Also da brauchst du sie noch nicht mehr schreiben. Sie kann da direkt tätig werden.
So, und es sind insgesamt 786 Schenkungen, die man sich hier angeschaut hat. Und bei 411 hat man nicht herausgefunden, um wie viel Geld es ging. Bei den 375, die man, weiß man, aber es sind 4,3 Milliarden, also so die Hälfte ungefähr. Bei der Hälfte kann man es nachvollziehen. Bei der anderen Hälfte weiß man nur, wer hat es denn bekommen. Und ja, es geht um Bildung, Kunst, Kultur. Und alle Organisationen, die dieses Geld bekommen von MacKenzie Scott, wissen das vorher nicht. Die haben sich nicht beworben, die sind nirgendwo damit hausieren gegangen, sondern die sind wirklich gefunden worden einfach. Das Team hat sich das einfach angeguckt, die Lage, und hat gesagt, so, euch geben wir das Geld. Und man hat dann die Organisation angeschrieben von Bloomberg aus. 90 Prozent, also von denen, die geantwortet haben, so 90 Prozent liegen zwischen 750.000 Dollar und 60 Millionen an einzelnen Beträgen. Also wir haben es ja wirklich mit erheblichen Schenkungen zu tun. Zum Beispiel der San Antonio College President, Robert Weller, 15 Millionen, einfach als E-Mail gekriegt, steht drin, wir möchten ihnen das schenken, ein Monat nicht dran geglaubt, zack, 15 Millionen eingestrichen, also Bildungseinrichtungen. Ansonsten sind es eher kleinere Organisationen. Die letzte Schätzung von Bloomberg geht davon aus, dass 58 Milliarden Dollar noch zur Verfügung stehen für diese Art. Also dass es jetzt noch 10, 15 Jahre in diesem Maße gehen könnte. Interessant ist halt, wie ihr Team da arbeitet. Denn während die Stiftung das immer über Verfahren und so weiter und die auch rechenschaftspflichtig sind und so weiter und so fort, ist das hier nicht gegeben. Wir haben es einfach mit einem Privatvermögen einer Frau zu tun, die ein Team beauftragt, dieses Geld einfach one way auszugeben, ohne irgendeine Formalität, ohne Zweckbindung, ohne alles.
Sie selbst, ohne dass sie kommt und sich nochmal fotografieren lässt mit dem großen Scheck.
Niemand, keine einzige Empfängerorganisation hat niemals mit Mackenzie Scott Kontakt gehabt. Es läuft immer nur über dieses Team. Die Hälfte der Organisationen, die unterstützt werden, hat gerade mal 50 Mitarbeiter. Also es ist auch nicht so, dass jetzt die Großen dann nochmal und so weiter, sondern sie sucht sich die kleinen Projekte raus, Stadtteilprojekte und so weiter. Und das Einzige, mit dem sie selbst in die Öffentlichkeit tritt, ist mit so einem Medium-Block. Also sie hat so ein Medium-Account und schreibt da immer mal so, auch in die Richtung, wie sie sich das so vorstellt, was so ein Geld bewirken soll, aber nicht konkret, auch nicht auf jemanden spezifisch, sondern einfach nur damit begleitet sie das so ein bisschen. Und es ist alles in allem dann doch erstaunlich. Man weiß über das Team wenig, über sie da nichts, sie äußert sich nicht. Und diese E-Mails, die kommen einfach. Da steht keine Telefonnummer drin, da ist kein Logo drin, da ist auch keine Adresse oder so genannt. Sonst einfach nur diese E-Mail, auf die man dann erst mal antworten soll. Und dann wird das so in die Wege geleitet. Und ich dachte mir so insgesamt, das ist wirklich Wahnsinn, inwieweit wir, wie soll man sagen, vielleicht hat sie auch so eine Art Sandel-Gedanken-Dings im Hintergrund und denkt sich einfach, bevor ich jetzt philosophisch für die Massen irgendwas aufschreibe oder so, nutze ich einfach das Geld, das mir da ist, um da so ein Prinzip umzudrehen. Keine Ahnung. Also es ist irgendwie, es hat so was Mystisches irgendwie, das so zu lesen, wie das so funktioniert. Und das Einzige, mit dem man Aufmerksamkeit erringen kann als Organisation, ist, dass man halt unter ihren Blogposts einfach kommentiert.
Ach so.
Mit mehr oder weniger Bittstellerei, dass man auf sich aufmerksam macht und wie auch immer. Ansonsten hat da einfach niemand Zugänge so zu ihr. Und sie hat dann in einem dieser Texte mal geschrieben, was ist ihr so wichtig, wenn sie spendet. Und dann schreibt sie so eine kleine Liste von, ja, dass die Leute auch mal wieder am Wochenende frei haben, ruhiger schlafen können und so weiter. Und als dann Celia Turner, eine der angesprochenen, die auch 4 Millionen bekommen hat für ihre Astrea Lesbian Foundation for Justice, meinte, ja, das hilft mir bei meiner Mental Health wirklich weiter, dieses Geld. Schließt der Text einfach von Bloomberg damit, ja, das ist wahrscheinlich das, was MacKenzie Scott da wollte. Dass Leute, die was Gutes tun, in ihrer Gesellschaft beitragen, das nicht an die große Glocke hängen, sondern in diesem ganz alltäglichen Struggle drin sind, selber viel mit Fundraising zu tun haben und so, also mit dieser quälenden Arbeit Geld einzusammeln, dass denen einfach so ein bisschen Handlungsvermögen gegeben wird und alle so ein bisschen besser schlafen können damit. Das ist irgendwie eine tolle Geschichte auch so insgesamt.
Ja, es ist so unglamorös und auf der anderen Seite hat man Jeff Bezos vor Augen. Also ich bin natürlich dagegen, dass wir in einer Gesellschaft leben, wo überhaupt ein solches Kapital sich aufsammeln kann und dass es dann in den Händen einer Person liegt, denn jetzt macht sie offenbar vernünftige Dinge damit. Sie könnte natürlich auch genau das Gegenteil damit tun und ganz andere Organisationen unterstützen. Aber dennoch ist es so bemerkenswert, weil man Jeff Bezos vor Augen hat, der einfach sagt, wie kann ich noch mehr Geld verprassen? Wie kann ich noch irgendeinen Unsinn machen? Wie kann ich dafür sorgen, dass es keine Gewerkschaften gibt? Und dann hat man da auf der anderen Seite diese Frauen. Man fragt sich auch, wie die mal zusammengefunden haben. Also was hat die mal moralisch verbunden? Denn das ist ja, glaube ich, schon etwas, was es für eine Beziehung braucht. Man muss nicht immer ideologisch ganz auf Linie sein, aber es muss doch so eine moralische Verbindung geben. Also dass man schon auf die Welt so blickt und nicht der eine sagt, na ja, hat halt Pech gehabt, hat sich offenbar nicht angestrengt. Und der andere sagt, nee, nee, hast du denn Michael Sandel nicht gelesen? Also ich glaube, wo das dann zu entgegengesetzt ist, funktioniert das nicht. Das ist ja hier ganz erstaunlich. Kann man vermutlich als Film kaum aufgreifen, müsste so eine wilde Farce werden. Aber ob das gelungen sein könnte, ich weiß es nicht.
Also du hast für niemanden Zugang, um das Drehbuch irgendwo zu mal festzuzorren, sondern du musstest dir halt alles ausdenken. Ihr keinen Kontakt und zu ihm natürlich auch nicht.
Ja, es ist viel Spekulation, aber wir können uns ja die andere Seite der Geschichte ansehen, in dem wir über Amazon reden. In The Intercept ist ein Artikel von Ken Klippenstein erschienen, der sich mit einem neuen Chat-Tool beschäftigt, das eingeführt werden soll, soll, noch ist es nicht da, für die Amazon-Mitarbeiter, also vor allem die im Lager. Zunächst mal haben wir ja etwas Freudiges zu verkünden. In Staten Island gibt es jetzt eine Gewerkschaft. Die ganze Zeit hat man ja das Versuch zu unterbinden und jetzt hat sich tatsächlich eine Amazon-Gewerkschaft gegründet und ich hoffe natürlich auch sehr, dass das jetzt den Effekt haben wird, dass da viele weitere entstehen. Aber zugleich können wir jetzt erleben, wie Amazon versucht, weiter Kontrolle über die Mitarbeiter auszuüben. Der Beitrag beginnt damit, dass es heißt, Amazon will Beiträge von Mitarbeitern auf einer geplanten internen Messaging-App blockieren und kennzeichnen, die Schlüsselwörter erhalten, die sich auf Gewerkschaften beziehen. Wie aus internen Unternehmensdokumenten hervorgeht, die von The Intercept eingesehen wurden. Eine automatische Wortüberwachung würde auch eine Reihe von Begriffen blockieren, die potenzielle Kritik an Amazons Arbeitsbedingungen darstellen. Was sind das also für Wörter, die da ausgeblendet werden sollen? Plantage, Gefängnis, Sklavenarbeit, Toiletten. Wir erinnern uns, da gab es diesen Skandal, die Amazon-Mitarbeiter sollten nicht auf Toilette gehen, sondern in Flaschen urinieren. Gekündigt, Entschädigung, Gehaltserhöhung, Mobbing, Belästigung. Auch Sätze, die mit Ich hasse anfangen. Oder auch der Satz, das ist besorgniserregend. Auch das soll herausgefiltert werden. Alles erst in Planung. Amazon hat jetzt auch gesagt, na ja, also wir sind da ja erst mal so am Prüfen. Das heißt im Artikel im November 2021 berief Amazon ein hochreiniges Treffen ein, bei dem Top-Führungskräfte Pläne zur Schaffung eines internen Social-Media-Programms diskutierten, mit dem Mitarbeiter die Leistung von Kollegen durch Shout-outs genannte Beiträge anerkennen können. So eine Quelle mit direkter Kenntnis. Und das finde ich genauso gruselig, wie das Löschen von Worten. Nämlich hier geht es ja eigentlich darum, dass man so Feedback-Schleifen einer Meritokratie errichtet, sodass jetzt auch die Kollegen untereinander sich in der 360-Grad-Perspektive überwachen, sich loben und damit dann natürlich auch ganz klar so einen Selektionsmechanismus etablieren. Das macht man dann hier zwar über das Lob, aber das heißt ja nichts anderes, wie dass der, der nicht genügend Lob bekommt, dann auch ganz schnell draußen ist. Das heißt im Artikel, das Hauptziel des Programms, so Amazonsleiter des weltweiten Verbrauchergeschäfts Dave Clark, sei es, die Mitarbeiterfluktuation zu verringern, indem die Zufriedenheit der Mitarbeiter gefördert werde und auch die Produktivität. Shoutouts wären Teil eines Belohnungssystems, bei dem Mitarbeiter virtuelle Sterne und Abzeichen für Aktivitäten erhalten, die einen direkten geschäftlichen Nutzen bringen. Und Dave Clark ist ganz begeistert, weil er sagt, einige Leute sind dann schon jetzt wahnsinnige Sternensammler. Also offenbar hat man schon so Tests gemacht. Und man hat sich auch versucht, da ein bisschen zu erklären, wie das dann mit diesem Bad-Word-Monitor aussieht. Aber das sei alles noch in der Planung. Aber eigentlich möchte man diese App so aufbauen wie Bumble. Das ist wie Tinder, also auch eine Datingplattform. Es soll doch so ganz konnektiv sein, dass Menschen sich auch miteinander verbinden. Aber in Wahrheit lesen wir natürlich heraus, worum es eigentlich geht. Man hat dann, glaube ich, noch so ein spielerisches Tool mit dazu und versucht so zu tun, als ginge es hier um soziale Interaktivität. Aber eigentlich geht es darum, dass Menschen Menschen permanent bewerten können. Und das Problem sei, wenn man freie Texte zulässt, also dass die sich Nachrichten schreiben können, dann könnten ja auch Inhalte produziert werden, heißt es dann da, die negative Gefühle bei den Empfängern hervorrufen. Und davor wollen sie natürlich die Menschen schützen und deswegen soll diese Bad-Word-Liste erstellt werden. Wiederum alles sehr gruselig, aber das ist Amazon, das ist dann nicht Jeff Bezos Frau, Ex-Frau.
Ja, und das ist so Wahnsinn, weil auf der einen Seite steht Joe Biden vorm Kongress und sagt, wir befinden uns hier im Wettstreit mit China, im Systemkampf gegen China. Wir wollen eine freie Gesellschaft, wir machen jetzt erstmal Familienförderung und so weiter. Gleichzeitig hast du dann Familieneltern, die in so einem China-Credit-Score-System sich irgendwie, das ist doch alles total bescheuert, ja? Also einfach China einführen kann doch eigentlich nicht die Lösung sein. Irre, irre, irre. Gut, wir haben in der März-Folge über Geothermie ganz kurz gesprochen, weil wir über Robert Zabecks Auftritt bei der Wohnbauwirtschaft sprachen. Und Geothermie ist, also man bohrt einen Loch im Boden und holt dann gewisse Wärme über so einen Kreislauf an Flüssigkeiten, die das irgendwie gut transportieren und so weiter und so fort.
Und da wurde ich ja darauf hingewiesen jetzt in zwei E-Mails. Es gibt sehr wohl Förderungen für diese Wärmepunkte. Und das habe ich auch vielleicht ein bisschen missverständlich ausgedrückt. Ja, es gibt Förderungen dafür. Aber gerade für Leute, die schon ein Haus haben, zum Beispiel Freunde von mir, die dann die Heizung ausgetauscht haben, weil die alte kaputt war, die bekommen zwar auch da irgendeine Förderung drauf, aber letztendlich sah die Rechnung so aus, die neue Gasheizung 10.000 Euro, das andere System 30.000 Euro. Und dann stellt sich die Frage eigentlich nicht mehr, was man dann bevorzugt.
Genau, bei Neubauten ist es so, dass mittlerweile 50-50 Gasheizung und dann Wärmewechseln im Boden über Geothermie gemacht wird. Man hat ja auch Solarthermie, also es sind ja nicht nur Solaranlagen, sondern eben auch Sonnenlicht, das einfach auf so eine komische Flüssigkeit, und die macht dann zumindest im Sommer das Duschwasser warm und so. Für die Heizung im Winter reicht es nicht ganz. Naja, die Solarthermie ist hier bei Heise Thema. Und zwar mit der Überschrift Geothermie mit Mikrowellen, tiefer bohren und heißer fördern. Der Kern des Planeten, wird darauf hingewiesen, ist wärmer als die Oberfläche der Sonne. Wir hätten also eine Quelle unbegrenzter und dauerhafter Energie, die als Wärme vorliegt. Und vor mehr als 100 Jahren haben wir mit Geothermie begonnen. Wir haben also Bohrlöcher gebaut, weniger 100 Meter tief. Das bedeutet ungefähr 150 Grad. Damit kann man nicht direkt Strom erzeugen, weil das für eine Dampfmaschine oder sowas nicht ausreicht. Man kann nur die Wärme nutzen dadurch. Also so Wäschereien oder so Wohnhäuser kriegt man damit warm. In Deutschland beträgt der Erdwärmeanteil derzeit vier Prozent der erneuerbaren Energien. Also da ist noch Potenzial. Und es ist eben grundsätzlich noch Potenzial. Wenn man 2050 klimaneutral werden will, müsste die Geothermie laut Internationaler Energieagentur, IEA, jährlich um 13 Prozent wachsen. Naja, auf diesem Pfad sind wir also nicht so richtig. Und in vulkanischen Gebieten wie Island oder so, da kommt man schon in drei bis fünf Kilometern so tief, dass man wirklich effizient Strom erzeugen kann. Das wäre in München anders. Da ist auch ein fünf Kilometer tiefes Loch nur 155 Grad warm. Plus ist es eine ganz schöne Entfernung, die man auch transportieren muss. Also in der Ansicht, das ist schon blöde. Fünf bis 20 Kilometer könnten allerdings überall auf der Welt ausreichend Energie bereitstellen. Oder ausreichend Wärme dann für Energieerzeugung. Und die Frage ist jetzt, wie? Weil 20 Kilometer tief bohren, also ist ja auch eine Herausforderung. Und ein Spin-off, und jetzt lese ich direkt, das Massachusetts Institute of Technology scheint dafür eine Lösung gefunden zu haben. Es verwendet Mikrowellen statt herkömmlicher Bohrer. Das Gyro-Tron, ein Mikrowellen-Generator einer Leistung, wie sie etwa bei Fusionsreaktoren zum Aufheizen des Plasmas zum Einsatz kommt, schickt gebündelt Hoch-Energie-Millimeter-Wellen in die Tiefe. Dort verdampft diese das Gestein. Ich denke gleich dual-use-mäßig wieder an Waffen und so. Aber man kann tatsächlich den Boden einfach verdampfen. Der ist dann pfff, löst sich einfach auf. Und ein abschließender Satz. Bis 2028 sollen die ersten Anlagen den kommerziellen Betrieb aufnehmen. Wenn das so aufgeht, wäre das natürlich eine Sensation. Denn wenn der Erdkern einfach reicht, um uns komplett und mit Energie zu versorgen und wir nutzen jetzt auch schon so ein bisschen Erdkern, aber im Sinne von der Lagerteilöl von früher und so weiter. Aber wenn wir diese Hitze wirklich einfach gebrauchen können für... Und dann kann man ja überlegen, wie man es am Ende konzipiert. Also das Bohrloch selbst nutzen, um da die Energieerzeugung zu bewerkstelligen oder wie auch immer. Also keine Ahnung, man liest jetzt mittlerweile doch so einige Sachen, bei denen man immer wieder denkt, cool, vielleicht brauchte die Welt jetzt mal wieder so einen kleinen Kick. Klar, der Ukraine-Krieg ist jetzt so einer, der auch die kleinsten Wäscherei noch mal überlegen lässt, ob sie nicht doch durch Wärme wechseln oder wie auch immer noch mal zehn Prozent irgendwo einsparen können. Und das scheint mir doch hier im Großen und Ganzen so ein richtiger Weg zu sein. Es gibt Dual-Use während eines Krieges auch immer ganz viel Antrieb, plötzlich ist doch alles auch mal wirklich im großen Sprung besser zu machen. Also verdampfen wir ab jetzt Gesteine.
Möglicherweise eine Lösung und hier haben die geopolitischen Bedingungen direkte Auswirkungen, die dann vielleicht eine ökologische Transformation beschleunigen. Man kann sich ja fragen, welche Effekte hat so etwas, was wir jetzt gerade tun, nämlich Sanktionieren auf Russland. Und die Idee ist ja erst einmal bei Sanktionen, man will ja nicht einfach nur Leute bestrafen, um sie zu bestrafen, sondern man möchte ja mit den Sanktionen auch einen Zweck erzielen, zum Beispiel, dass Putin mit diesem Krieg aufhört. Und jetzt hatte ich schon dieses Buch, The Economic Weapon von Nicolas Molder gelesen und war dann etwas desillusioniert, weil er dann mal solche Erhebungen macht und sagt, wie wirksam sind denn eigentlich. Sanktionen und wirksam, damit meine ich, haben sie die Wirkung, die sie haben sollen im politischen Sinne. Also sie wirken natürlich die Sanktionen jetzt gegen Russland sehr hart, aber bewirken die auch das, was wir da eigentlich wollen, oder haben die irgendwelche anderen Effekte. Und diese Frage, die hat sich auch die Journalistin Farida Rostamova gestellt. Sie war bei der BBC, ist jetzt unabhängig, ich mach jetzt auch bei Substack einen Newsletter, der hochinteressant ist zu lesen. Und es gibt einen sehr langen Text, der sich aber lohnt. Der heißt, now we are going to fuck them all. What's happening in Russia's elites after a month of war? Sanctions and propaganda have rallied even those who were against the invasion around Putin. Und dieser Artikel beginnt mit einem Disclaimer. Da sagt sie, dieser Artikel hätte schon früher erscheinen können, aber ich wollte so viele Informationen wie möglich sammeln, um sicherzustellen, dass ich nicht manipuliert werde. Also auch interessant, wie kann man überhaupt noch als Journalist jetzt aus Ostland Informationen an ein Publikum bringen, wo man sagt, ja, die Informationen stimmen, aber auch da bin ich jetzt gerade nicht manipuliert wurde. Ich wollte nicht noch eine profane Überschrift verwenden, aber nachdem ich mit vielen Leuten gesprochen hatte, wurde mir klar, dass dieses Zitat wirklich viel aussagt. Und dann bringt sie das ganze Zitat. Da sie Sanktionen gegen uns beschlossen haben, werden wir sie ficken. Jetzt müssen sie Rubel an der Moskauer Börse kaufen, um bei uns Gas zu kaufen, aber das ist nur der Anfang, sagt ein hochrangiger russischer Beamter mit Begeisterung. Er ist seit langem Mitglied von Putins Team, gilt aber als liberaler Denker. Vor einem Monat vertrat er noch eine andere Haltung und sagte, mit einigem Bedauern das Wichtigste sei, das Blutvergießen in der Ukraine zu beenden und dann herauszufinden, wie man in der neuen Realität leben könne. Da war er nicht der Einzige. In Russland gibt es aber keine illoyalen Menschen mehr an der Macht. Aber es gibt Beamte und es gibt Angestellte, es gibt Leiter von staatlichen Unternehmen, es gibt Abgeordnete regierungsnahe Wirtschaftseliten und sie alle, schreibt die Autorin, äußerten in privaten Gesprächen zumindest Fassungslosigkeit über den Einmarsch in der Ukraine. Im vergangenen Monat gab es jedoch keinen Massenexodus von Beamten oder Staatsmanagern. Die großen Unternehmen schweigen entweder oder beschränken sich auf neutrale Phrasen. Also das heißt, in der Öffentlichkeit gibt es diese Kritik nicht. Aber wenn man mal so ein bisschen nachhört, dann hat man die schon auch gehört. In der vergangenen Woche habe ich mit mehreren Putin nahestehenden Personen sowie mit etwa einem Dutzend Beamter verschiedener Ebenen und Angestellten staatlicher Unternehmen gesprochen. Ich hatte zwei Ziele. Erstens wollte ich die Stimmung unter den russischen Eliten und den ihnen nahestehenden Personen nach der Verhängung der beispiellosen Sanktionen gegen Russland verstehen. Zweitens wollte ich herausfinden, ob jemand versucht, Präsident Putin davon zu überzeugen, das Blutvergießen zu beenden. Nun, was hat sie herausgefunden? Man kann sagen, dass im letzten Monat Putins Traum von einer Konsolidierung der russischen Elite in Erfüllung gegangen ist. Diese Menschen haben verstanden, dass ihr Leben nur noch mit Russland verbunden ist und dass sie es dort aufbauen müssen. Jemand aus dem Kreml sagt ihr, wir haben den Punkt überschritten, an dem es kein Zurück mehr gibt. Jeder versteht, dass es Frieden geben wird, aber dass dieser Frieden nicht das Leben zurückbringen wird, das wir vorher hatten. Und sie sagt dann weiter, meine Quellen. Zufolge hat sich auch die russische Gesellschaft unter dem Druck der Propaganda und den Folgen der Sanktionen für das Vorgehen von Putin stark gemacht. Die Propaganda ist ganz enorm. Sie sagt dann noch mal, am Anfang haben wir ja Menschen auf der Straße gesehen. Wir haben auch Künstler und Wissenschaftler, Schriftsteller erlebt, die offene Briefe geschrieben haben, die Petitionen unterzeichnet haben. Doch das ist jetzt nicht mehr der Fall. Innerhalb einer Woche hatten die Behörden fast alle unabhängigen Medien blockiert und geschlossen. Bürger wurden eingeschüchtert. Straßenproteste endeten in Verhaftungen. Und so ist es jetzt laut einer Umfrage, dass 75 Prozent der russischen Bevölkerung die sogenannte Militäroperation unterstützt. Und sie sagt dann, die von mir befragten Personen sagten übereinstimmt, dass die Sanktionen und andere wirtschaftliche und politische Folgen des Krieges für viele einfache Bürger das Gegenteil von dem bewirkt haben, was die westlichen Länder vielleicht beabsichtigt hatten. Der massenhafte Rückzug westlicher Marken, Ikea, Apple, Zara, McDonalds, Karlsberg, all dies hat bei den Russen den Eindruck erweckt, dass die ganze Welt gegen sie ist. Nun ist das die russische Bevölkerung, aber wie ist es mit den Eliten? Da zitiert sie dann gleich wieder einen hochrangigen Beamten, mit dem sie gesprochen hat. Natürlich keine Namen. Da sagt dieser Beamte zu ihr, als ich sah, was sie diesem armen Paralympioniken antaten, die wurden ja da auch verbannt, war es das für mich? Ich pfeife auf iPhones, ich kann ein chinesisches Telefon benutzen. Ich habe ein deutsches Auto, lass mich stattdessen ein chinesisches oder ein russisches fahren. Jetzt verstehe ich, dass der Chef recht hat, dass diese ganze Sache so oder so passieren musste, sie hätten diese Sanktionen sowieso verhängt. Und das war jemand, der noch vor über einem Monat diese imperialen Ambitionen von Russland als sehr kritisch eingestuft hat. Nach Ansicht mehrerer Personen, schreibt die Autorin, auf verschiedenen Macht-Ebenen haben die persönlichen Sanktionen Putin einen großen Gefallen getan, da sie ihm geholfen haben, das zu erreichen, was ihm viele Jahre lang nicht gelungen war, die russischen Eliten zu einem nahezu monolithischen Gebilde zu machen. Und erstaunlich ist auch, dass wir dann natürlich auch Leute erleben, die jetzt in die Zukunft irgendwie planen. Und da sagt einer aus einem Staatsunternehmen, jeder der über ein neues Leben nachgedacht hat, versteht, dass sich sein Leben zumindest für die nächsten 10 bis 15 Jahre auf Russland konzentriert, dass seine Kinder in Russland studieren werden, dass seine Familie in Russland leben wird. Diese Menschen fühlen sich beleidigt. Sie werden niemanden umstürzen, sondern ihr Leben hier aufbauen. Also es gibt ja diese Idee, die Opposition hat bald genügend Kraft, werden sich dann alle gegen Putin stemmen. Offenbar, zumindest nach dieser Recherche, ist das nicht der Fall. Und es ist sogar so, dass die Autorinnen diagnostiziert, früher standen sich die Normalbevölkerung und die Eliten fast feindlich gegenüber. Zumindest waren sie sehr weit voneinander entfernt. Und inzwischen setzt sich immer mehr dieses Gefühl, wir sind alle im selben Boot durch. Man kann das auch noch mal vom Alter her aufschlüsseln. Da sagt sie, viele ältere Menschen, die sehen jetzt eine große Chance. Da heißt es, sie sehen die Chance, Geld zu verdienen und neu anzufangen. Genau wie in den 90er Jahren. Sie zitiert dann da jemanden aus dem Management eines sanktionierten staatlichen Unternehmens. Sie denken, wir sind dumm. Wir sind nicht dumm. Wir sind Russen. Das ist gar nichts. Jetzt werden wir mobilisieren. Wir werden arbeiten. Und Menschen, aber die jünger sind, also zwischen 45 und 50, die das Ende der Sowjet-Ära in ihrer Jugend miterlebt haben, gehen ebenfalls ihren Geschäften nach, aber nicht mit diesem Enthusiasmus. Da heißt es von einer Quelle, jetzt ist es viel wichtiger zu verstehen, wie wir unter diesen Bedingungen leben werden. Aber auch da gibt man sich technokratisch und stützt das System. Frustriert sind die, die zwischen 35 und 40 sind, weil sie ja doch einige Errungenschaften jetzt verloren haben. Aber auch die reagieren zornig mit Blick auf den Westen. Da sagt einer der jüngsten Informanten, mit dem sie gesprochen hat, der sagt, ich möchte ihnen sagen, dass sie einfach die Klappe halten sollen. Und ein anderer junger Beamter, der den Krieg nicht unterstützt, sagt, er fühle sich gefangen, es ist unerträglich zu bleiben, aber es ist unmöglich zu kündigen und das Land zu verlassen, denn niemand lässt ihn ausreisen. Mit Putin selbst kann man nicht mehr sprechen. Also es ist genau die These von Mascha Gessen, die du uns vorgespielt hast. Der Putin sitzt da, alleine schützt sich vor Corona und vor allem davor, dass irgendjemand mit ihm redet, der den Krieg nicht toll findet. Die Autoren schreiben, diejenigen, denen es gelingt, mit Putin zu sprechen, beklagen sich darüber, dass er selbst zwar ernsthaft spricht, aber nicht besonders gut zuhört, was man ihm sagt. Das sagt eine Person, die im letzten Monat mit dem Präsidenten gesprochen hat. Kann man die Meinung ändern? Da sind sich alle einig, das ist bei Putin nutzlos und sinnlos. Putin will unbedingt militärisch gewinnen. Niemand kann etwas fordern. Sie können sich unterhalten, sagt jemand, aber es nützt nichts. Er hat ein klares Bild in seinem Kopf, dass er allen unter die Nase reibt. Und auch ganz erstaunlich, im vergangenen Monat gab es kein öffentlich bekanntgegebenes persönliches Treffen zwischen Putin und jemanden aus der russischen Elite, der sich aus ideologischen Gründen gegen den Krieg aussprechen könnte. Sie zählt dann noch ein paar auf, den Finanzminister Kudrin, der in gewisser Weise skeptisch dem gegenüberstehen könnte. Aber da sagt man auch gar, das ist eine Art Selbstmord, sich da anders zu äußern. Dann gibt es noch die Vorsitzende der Zentralbank, Elvira Nabiolina, auch hoch angesehen. Sie soll auch eigentlich dem skeptisch gegenüberstehen, aber man kann nicht davon ausgehen, dass sie das mit Putin verhandelt. Das ist alles nicht denkbar. Es gibt einen einzigen, nämlich der Berater des Präsidenten für Nachhaltige Entwicklung, Antoli Dschubais. Der hat sich dagegen gestellt. Er ist aber auch ausgewandert jetzt. Er ist mit seiner Frau in die Türkei in Urlaub und ist nicht wiedergekommen. Da wird aber auch noch angemerkt, das war somit der unbeliebteste Politiker in ganz Russland. Und der ist jetzt weg und hatte ohnehin keinen guten Zugang zu Putin. Bleibt noch der Oligarch Roman Abramowitsch. Zelensky soll ja bei beiden Gerüchte gefordert haben, dass Abramowitsch nicht unter die Sanktionen fällt, weil er so als vielleicht neutraler Verhandler auftreten könnte. Da zerfrannt sich der Text am Ende, bzw. da tappt er auch im Dunkeln und weiß nicht, welche Rolle Abramowitsch spielen kann oder könnte, sollte. Es ist auf jeden Fall alles sehr, sehr düster. Und zu glauben, dass da irgendwo jetzt durch diese Krise ein bisschen frischer Wind weht, dass sich da Eliten gegen Putin stellen, scheint wohl, je nachdem, was wir hier lesen können, nicht der Fall zu sein. Und zugleich stehen wir ja auch wie der Ochs vom Berg, weil wir gar nicht wissen, naja gut, wenn das jetzt nicht so funktioniert, was machen wir dann? Also Niklas Mulder hatte, bevor Putin den Krieg erklärte, mal vorgeschlagen, was wäre eigentlich, wenn der Westen jetzt ganz auf Russland zugehen würde und sagen, hier, wir bauen was mit den Sanktionen, das lassen wir jetzt. Also es gab ja schon vor dem Krieg was. Ob das eine Möglichkeit gewesen wäre, aber das ist reine Spekulation. Und jetzt weiß man nicht, was man machen soll, denn die Sanktionen jetzt wegzulassen, würde nichts ändern, sie beizubehalten. Konsolidiert weiterhin Putins Macht. Es ist also eine wirklich verfahrene Situation. Das hat man nach dieser Lektüre des langen Textes begriffen.
Ja, aber ich würde dort schon mal scharf darauf verweisen, dass wir noch in der ersten Phase sind sozusagen. Wir sind jetzt gerade noch, wenn man das mit der Corona-Pandemie vergleicht, in diesem April 2020. Wir bleiben zu Hause. Genau, alle sitzen noch in einem Boot. Klar, man fühlt sich erst mal gut regiert von der Regierung. Keiner weiß was und so weiter. Und ich kann mir schon vorstellen, dass sich dieses Bild in den nächsten Monaten auch noch mal sehr wandelt. Gerade wenn dann, also derzeit, man sagt immer Propaganda, man weiß aber gar nicht genau, was im Fernsehen läuft. Aber die Nachrichten sind dort gerade doppelt so lang in Russland. Und es gibt jeden Abend Talkshows, die es vorher nicht gab, die sich mit dem Konflikt da befassen. Und in der Hinsicht ist das schon so eine thematische, die sich auch ausläuft irgendwann. Also das kann man nicht über Jahre hypernormalisieren. Und daher glaube ich, es gibt schon noch mal jetzt auch einen Anlass zur Geduld, sich das genauer anzuschauen. Denn auf der einen Seite diskutieren wir immer, ja, wenn die jetzt ihr Öl kappen für uns, dann bedeutet das das totale Ende Deutschlands. Auf der anderen Seite glauben wir immer, ja, das bedeutet da alles gar nichts. Und ich glaube, irgendwas bedeutet es schon und es braucht einfach nur Geduld. Dieser Wirtschaftskrieg läuft einfach auf so einer anderen Zeitdimension als diese Bombe, die einfach puff, und dann ist sie explodiert.
Meine große Sorge ist nur, dass diese Leute, die sich da jetzt geäußert haben, das vielleicht doch noch eine lange Zeit zu sehen wird, die werden ja nicht untätig bleiben. Die sagen jetzt nicht, wir warten mal ab, mal gucken, ob am Ende noch Geld da ist. Sondern die versuchen ja neue Verbindungen herzustellen. Und wenn das mit dem Westen nicht mehr geht, dann steht da indienbereit, dann steht da chinabereit, oder Pakistan, und da ist ja noch ganz viel. Also da sind ja auch einfach demographisch betrachtet sehr viele Leute, mit denen man Geschäfte machen kann. Und dass sich dadurch Machtblöcke bildet, die wir dann nicht mehr so unter Kontrolle haben. Denn jetzt ist das noch ganz klar in der westlichen Hegemonie, inklusive Dollar und Zwift und und und. Aber was ist, wenn sich das da noch viel stärker ausbildet und in der Richtung geht, dass wir dann vielleicht gar nicht mehr die Macht der Sanktionen haben? Also das ist ja etwas, was wir jetzt gut machen können, weil wir überhaupt diese Infrastruktur zur Verfügung stellen. Aber das ist so, wenn es nur die deutsche Bahn gibt, dann kann die sagen, sie fährt oder sie fährt nicht. Aber wenn ich auf den Flixbus umsteigen kann, dann ist das was anderes. Und das ist etwas, dass wir so eine neue Welt der Machtblöcke erleben, was in gewisser Weise sehr beängstigend ist. Denn man kann es so schwer sagen, ob die Geschäfte nicht auch für diese Leute sehr gut weitergehen können, wenn man sich vom Westen losgekoppelt hat. Klar, da wird es erstmal die eine oder andere Rezession geben. Aber möglicherweise ist das auch etwas, wo wir gerade ein bisschen abgewickelt werden.
Ja, aber noch, glaube ich, lohnt sich der Hinweis darauf, dass sich das russische Leben vor allem an der Westküste abspielt und das chinesische vor allem an der Ostküste des jeweiligen Landes, das da zwischen 6.000 Kilometer sind. Dass China wahnsinnig viel nach Europa, also Europa ist der wichtigste Handelspartner von China. Irgendwie 50% der Exporter oder so, wie auch immer. Nach Russland sind es so 3 oder 4%. Also selbst wenn man das jetzt so richtig hochskaliert im zigprozentigen Bereich Wachstum und so weiter, ist das immer noch Jahre und Jahrzehnte davon entfernt. Und Russland ist dann auch irgendwann gedeckelt. Also so viel Vermögen und so viel Publikum und Konsum gibt es da auch nicht so abzugreifen für China, dass da jetzt irgendwie die Komplettausbeutung Russlands auch nur nennenswert irgendwas ändert in der Bilanzierung. Denn dafür ist Russland auch einfach zu klein. Es sind 120 Millionen Menschen, die in der volkswirtschaftlichen Kraft so auf Niveau Italien sind. Ich würde sagen, mal gucken, wie es nächstes Jahr ist. Weil der Krieg wird auch noch lange dauern. Stoltenberg meinte schon Monate und Jahre. Und diese Wirtschaftssachen, das ist ja nun wirklich langfristig angelegt. Deswegen ja auch die große Angst von Robert Habeck, nichts beschließen zu müssen, was man irgendwann absehbar wieder zurücknehmen muss, sondern erst mal so ein Status Quo einfach zu zementieren. Nicht Krieg, aber auch hoch her geht's ja bei Twitter. Denn Twitter ist unser Schlachtfeld. Wir betonen es ja immer wieder so ein bisschen. Wir können nicht ganz auf Twitter verzichten, haben aber auch gesehen, Twitter ist jetzt 15 Jahre oder so an der Börse und war im Grunde 15 Jahre lang oder zumindest jetzt immer genau auf dem Stand, wo sie auch in den Markt eintraten. Also da war im Vergleich zu den ganzen anderen Überflieger in der Silicon Valley einfach keine große Marktkapitalisierung abzugreifen. Und jetzt hat sich aber Elon Musk gedacht, ich kaufe mich mal bei Twitter ein und Max Jeffkin, wir kennen ihn, wir haben sein Buch über Peter Thiel gelesen. Und er schreibt bei Bloomberg. Das ist ganz witzig, weil er den Text beginnt mit, Hi, it's Max Jeffkin in New York. So als würde er so einen Brief schreiben, wie die Mediziner vor 100 Jahren in ihrer großen Fondanz. Und er möchte uns gerne sagen, dass Elon Musk jetzt Twitter's largest shareholder ist, was wir natürlich wissen, weshalb wir diesen Text lesen. Und es ist ganz witzig, zwischen der Herausforderung Vladimir Putins zu einem Boxkampf und einem Kommentar zur Türpolitik des Berliner Berghains beides auf Twitter ausgetragen. Von Elon Musk hat er sich bei Twitter bereichert. Es gehört zu seinem Masterplan, sagt Jeff Kin. Das eine ist Tesla seit 2006. Einfach zu sagen, das soll ein gigantischer Automotive and Renewable Energy Company werden. Also er möchte die Welt retten mit dieser Unternehmerschaft usw. Auf dieser Ebene ist auch dieses Twitter-Game jetzt anzusehen. Seit die Nachricht publik wurde, bis Jeff Kin schrieb, hat Elon Musk nur einen Tweet geschrieben. Oh hi, lol, Punkt. Also wie man ihn halt kennt. Und das geht aber auch schon so in die Richtung. Denn jetzt fragen sich natürlich alle, was soll denn das? Wieso macht er das denn? Macht er das nur für die Lulz? Und dann kann man sagen, klar, das ist Elon Musk. Worum sollte es ihm sonst gehen? Twitters Kurs sprang durch diesen Invest um 27%. Was bedeutet, und das muss man sich immer wieder vergegenwärtigen, Elon Musk hat das größte Vermögen der Welt, das größte Privatvermögen der Welt. Und wenn er Twitter kauft, 10% von Twitter, gibt er damit kein Geld aus, sondern er verwandelt ja nur Geld in Geld. Also es ist nur Bargeld in Aktienbesitz. Durch diesen Move steigt aber die Marktkapitalisierung von Twitter um 27%, was für seinen 10%igen Anteil bedeutet. Er hat Geld ausgegeben und wurde 800 Millionen Dollar reicher. Innerhalb dieses Tages wurde das geschah. Also es ist einfach immer wieder beeindruckend. Und einige fragen sich zum Beispiel Matt Levine, was will er denn? Und wird dann hier zitiert mit, der hat doch schon das ganze Geld. Also kann es ihm nur um, wenn ich jetzt bei Twitter einen Move mache, dann springe ich da rein und dann habe ich so ein 800 Millionen Tagesgewinn, wenn ich das da wieder veräußere oder so? Ne, das kann es nicht sein, weil er hat ja schon das ganze Geld. Find ich auch eine sehr gute Erklärung. Also Geld geht es da nicht mehr an diesen Regionen. Max Jeffkin sagt dann hier einfach, es geht darum, dass Elon Musk mit diesem Move seinen wichtigsten Marketing-Channel für sich preserves, absichert. Dass er sich da einfach einkauft, sodass auch alle wissen, naja, die werden da jetzt auch nicht da sitzen und ihm beim nächsten Move irgendwie den Account sperren, wo wir ja schon gesehen haben, dass sie es selbst bei amerikanischen Präsidenten machen oder ehemaligen Präsidenten. Also um sich da so ein bisschen abzusichern. Dann hat Elon Musk ja schon mit der SEC Sorgen gehabt, weil er damals diesen einen Tweet schrieb mit, ich habe das Funding schon gesichert, soll ich jetzt Tesla an irgendwelche saudischen oder so verkaufen? Ich weiß nicht mehr genau, da kam die ja zu ihm und meinten, also hör mal zu, du kannst dir nicht auf Twitter deine eigenen Börsenwerte, relevanten Informationen so lancieren, dass wir danach nicht genau nachvollziehen können, ob du hier gerade irgendwen betrügst oder so. Weil das hat einen direkten Einfluss auf die Kurse und das wissen auch alle. Und er selber ist aber Shareholder von dem ganzen Kram, könnte da auch für sich einfach zu viel rausholen. Weshalb er in relativ vielen Angelegenheiten, nämlich immer wenn nachträglich festgestellt wird, hier hast du aber mal wieder zum Thema Twitter, Smart-Kapitalisierung und Aktienwert getwittert und so, dass er eigentlich dann immer nachweisen muss, im Vorfeld mit Juristen über diesen Tweet geredet zu haben. Was natürlich blöd ist, weil er ja so Impuls-Twitterer ist. Also da sind ihm schon so ein bisschen die Fesseln angelegt. Weshalb man hier eben nicht so richtig weiterkommt. Aber, und am Ende geht es vielleicht doch einfach ums Geld. Im Sinne von Elon Musk hat ein Leben aufgebaut, das ihm einfach unfassbar viel Geld sichert. Und da spielt Twitter einfach eine maßgebende Rolle. Dieser Tag, als Elon Musk Twitter, also sich mit 10% Twitter einkaufte, ist auch Teslas Aktienkurs um 5,6% gestiegen. Was bedeutet, dass dieses Investment in Twitter, dass Elon Musk auch sein Wesen absichert, weltweit öffentlich so zu handeln, wie er handelt, 13 Milliarden Dollar Gewinn an diesem einen Tag beschert hat? Und da sind wir wieder in Regionen, wo man sagen muss, da geht es dann auch ums Geld. Das sind nicht 800 Millionen, sondern das sind 13 Milliarden. Und am Ende ist das eine Investition in die Stütze seines bisherigen Lebens.
Glaubst du, dass Twitter jetzt durch den Krieg eine neue Relevanz gewonnen hat? Wir haben zwar jetzt viel über den TikTok-Krieg gesprochen, wie weit da TikTokker gebrieft werden, wie das für Propaganda missbraucht wird, wie aber auch Politiker, letztendlich auch Zelensky, im TikTok-Modus vom Krieg berichten. Und zugleich stelle ich doch fest, dass Twitter enorm wichtig ist zur Informationsbeschaffung. Auch unser eins wird ja sicherlich nochmal auf Quellen aufmerksam über Twitter. Im Hinblick auf den Krieg, die wir sonst nicht wahrgenommen hätten, hat Twitter damit nochmal eine andere Relevanz und Wertigkeit erhalten, als das zuvor der Fall war. Denn wir hatten ja so einen gewissen Twitter-Knick. Trump ist raus, jetzt ist also dieser Spaß vorbei. Auch der zum Teil ernste Spaß. Dann hatten wir Corona. Da gab es natürlich auch so einen Twitter-Run am Anfang. Aber dann war das ja auch ganz gut, könnte man das ja ohne Twitter lösen, weil man eigentlich da diese ganzen News-Apps hatte. Aber jetzt habe ich irgendwie den Eindruck, dass doch Twitter wieder so eine große Relevanz hat, auch gerade in Bezug auf die Threats, die erstellt werden. Zu dem, was ist denn da jetzt eigentlich gerade passiert, wenn da 200, 300 Menschen abgeschlachtet wurden. Und dann berichten Leute und vergleichen das vielleicht mit anderen ähnlichen Funden von Leichen oder von Gewalttaten aus Kriegen. Also ich habe irgendwie so den Eindruck, dass Twitter doch nochmal wichtiger geworden ist. Also im Sinne von Qualität.
Also meine Feststellung ist eher, dass auf Twitter durch den Krieg und so weiter wieder mehr stattfindet als natürlich so in ruhigen Zeitlagen, auch in den ruhigen Corona-Lagen. Also es hat jetzt wieder so eine Relevanz. Ich würde aber sagen, es wird nur Menschen wieder deutlicher, so wie du jetzt diese Frage stellst. Weil für mich ist Twitter immer wahnsinnig relevant gewesen. Also wenn ich jetzt mal meine Sicht zentral setze, für mich war Twitter immer wahnsinnig relevant. Und ich merke es immer dann, wenn mich wirklich was interessiert, wenn ich mich nicht einfach treiben lassen will. Das kann man bei Instagram, bei TikTok und so weiter. Da weiß man einfach nie, ist das Video von heute, von gestern, ist doch egal. Bei Twitter kommt es auf jede Sekunde an. Und über diese Zeitdimension ist eine erhebliche Relevanz drin, die kein anderes soziales Medium auch nur annähernd reproduzieren kann. Du machst Twitter auf, gehst oben auf neueste Tweets, gibst ein Schlagwort ein und kriegst dann auch wirklich das neueste. Und Scott Galloway beschreibt es ja auch immer wieder, Twitter ist mitten drin in unser aller Leben, selbst wenn wir es nicht benutzen, weil es immer, der Jack Dorsey hat das mal so beschrieben, als es ist das Bewusstsein der Öffentlichkeit. Also Twitter repräsentiert das, was so das Bewusstsein ist. Wenn man sich mal kurz andocken will, guckt man bei Twitter nach. Kein anderes Medium macht das. Aber Twitter kann das eben nicht monetarisieren. Haben sie nie gekonnt. Es waren auch nie die großen Versuchungen da, wie bei Instagram jedes dritte Bild Werbung sein zu lassen. Ja, so jeden dritten Tweet, das hat alles nicht funktioniert. Dieses ganze Promoten von einzelnen Tweets hat auch nicht funktioniert. Ja, so eine Spielerei, die man sich dann einfach genommen hat. Klar, irgendwann ploppt man einer oben auf, aber man hört dann nicht wirklich mit zu. Das ist super selten. In der Ansicht ist Twitter immer super relevant und war aber nie monetarisierbar, aber immer groß genug, um eigenständig zu sein. Und ich glaube, Elon Musk geht es auch darum, so einer Gefahr zu entgehen, dass Twitter wirklich mal aufgekauft wird von Google oder so. Und dann einfach so eingehegt wird in so ein größeres, nicht mehr eigenständig, und dann einfach so auf Funktionen runtergedimmt irgendwie. Und jetzt ist auf jeden Fall wieder gesichert, dass Twitter eigenständig weitermacht, wie es weitermacht. Und die haben auch schon angekündigt, demnächst wird es einen Edit-Button geben, sodass man einen Tweet für die Leserlichkeit irgendwie noch mal berichtigen kann, aber trotzdem immer nachvollziehbar ist, was war der Ursprungstweet. Beispielsweise, wenn sich viele darüber aufregen, dass man wirklich noch mal die Versionsgeschichte kennt. Also solche Sachen, die natürlich alle super nützlich sind. Diese Threads lassen sich ja auch heute sehr viel besser lesen als früher noch. Weil Twitter einfach verstanden hat, da muss man jetzt mal Wert drauflegen. Wenn man den anklickt, kriegt man dann auch den ganzen Thread und nicht alle Replies dazwischen noch und so. Also so an Feinheiten sieht man, dass sie wirklich dran arbeiten und eigentlich wissen, woran der Wert ihres Dings liegt. Es geht noch alles immer wahnsinnig langsam bei Twitter.
Und als Videoplattform ja auch wichtig. Mir ist aufgefallen, dass ich das deutsche Fernsehen fast nur noch über Twitter wahrnehme, weil immer wieder da Clips erscheinen. Dann ist dann eine einstündige Talkshow und ich bekomme dann in 60 Sekunden so einen Habeck-Auftritt, wo Habeck das noch mal ganz klar zurückspielt an Markus Lanz und sagt, wann haben Sie denn mal eine Markus Lanz-Sendung darüber gemacht, wo wir eigentlich unser Öl herbekommen, um die Autos zu tanken? So Sachen sehe ich über Twitter.
Habeck bei Lanz und dann gab es ja diesen Tweet von Laschet, wo er Laschet schrieb. Also das ist echt Zeitenwende, wie der Habeck da redet. Das ist ja beeindruckend und so. Und dieses Video hat unser Matthias gemacht. Du hast das auch gar nicht gesehen, sondern er hat dann nur im Nachhinein gesehen, viele Views da drauf, wo kamen die her. Da hat er so bei Twitter das Dashboard nachgeguckt. Ah, weil Laschet das verbreitet hatte. Genau, für sowas ist Twitter dann wahnsinnig gut. Und ich finde das auch wahnsinnig witzig. Und Twitter ist einfach superrelevant. Es ist kein Leben ohne Twitter denkbar.
Doch, doch, doch, doch, doch. Also ich möchte jetzt, hier werden uns Leute zuhören, die kein Twitter haben und ich kann das nur begrüßen. Ich glaube, dass man sehr, sehr genau mit Twitter umgehen muss. Und ich glaube, man muss sehr viel muten, dann vielleicht, um das nicht wahrzunehmen. Oder diese ganzen Hashtags, also wenn man mal nur schaut, was in den Trends täglich ist, dann ist ja eins blöder als das andere. Es ist eher, also du kannst es anders nutzen, klar. Und das mache ich ja auch. Und so komme ich ja auch dann zum Beispiel auf diesen eben vorgestellten Text über die russischen Eliten. Den habe ich über Twitter gefunden. Aber wenn ich sehe, was da so auf der rechten Seite passiert, also was da in den Trends angezeigt wird, dann finde ich, ist das eine unglaubliche Verblödung des Diskurses. Und deswegen, glaube ich, muss man sich da sehr prüfen, am besten gar nicht diesen Riesenprofilen folgen. Und ich sage mal, man bekommt ohnehin noch genügend von denen mit, selbst wenn man gar niemanden mehr von denen folgt. Also es ist doch ein sehr zweischneidiges Schwert, dieses Twitter. Ich glaube allerdings auch, dass man da eher in dem Gedanken hinkommt, weil man informiert werden will. Das ist jetzt bei Instagram nicht so der Fall. Das mag aber bei jüngeren Leuten anders sein. Also diese Influencer, die so ein bisschen politische Inhalte machen, die, glaube ich, haben schon eine Community, die sich nicht über Twitter informiert. Man weiß ja auch, dass ganz wenige Leute in Deutschland nur bei Twitter angemeldet sind. Vergleich zu Instagram ist es, glaube ich, ein Zehntel. Also gibt es schon Leute, die sich bei Instagram informieren. Ich denke aber auch, dass Instagram allein schon von der Struktur her nicht eine sinnvolle Informationsplattform ist. Gerade weil auch so viel am Körper immer festgemacht wird. Das ist ja auch bei den politischen Inhalten. Während Twitter, wenn wir jetzt gerade kein Video sehen, ziemlich körperlos ist, sondern tatsächlich ein Textmedium ist. Während wir es bei einem Bildmedium mit weniger Text zu tun haben bei Instagram. Und vielleicht auch deshalb ist Instagram ja auch so ein Ersatz-Tinder. Also ich glaube, es ist so ein Tinder. Einmal für die, die sich nicht bei Tinder anmelden wollen. Und man kann es ein bisschen indirekter durch die Plume. Also man kann sich ein Kompliment machen, ohne dass es gleich heißt, sollen wir uns heute Abend daten. Das, glaube ich, ist dann bei Instagram nochmal so etwas. Das kann ich mir jetzt bei Twitter eher nicht vorstellen, dass das passiert. Aber Twitter wird sicherlich diese Relevanz behalten, vielleicht dann sogar nochmal noch wichtiger werden. Ich möchte ja eigentlich jetzt gerne von Max Schäfken mal eine Elon Musk Biografie lesen, denn es gibt nur so Lopudeleien auf Elon Musk. Das wäre doch ganz gut.
Also er hat im Text erwähnt, dass er ihn häufig traf zum Interview. Es scheint da noch ein Fundus an Textstücken zu geben, die man echt mal verbraten könnte. Wer weiß, woran er arbeitet, ja.
Prima, wir gehen in die Stadt. Die Soziologin Martina Löw wurde in Brand 1, hatten wir das letzte Mal schon was aus Brand 1, glaube ich, in Brand 1 befragt zur Stadt. Genau, das war zu Ikea damals. Und jetzt geht es darum, brauchen Unternehmen überhaupt Büros? Wie ist das und wie nehmen wir Räume wahr? Sie ist Stadtsoziologin, beschäftigt sich seit vielen, vielen Jahren damit. Und auch die Fragen, die sie gestellt bekommt, die muss man ausdrücklich loben. Loben von Peter Lautenbach sind die Fragen gestellt. Und da heißt es nach Angaben des Immobiliendienstleisters BNP, bauten oder kauften Unternehmen in Deutschland 2021 Büroimmobilien für mehr als 30 Milliarden Euro. Mehr als vor der Pandemie. Haben sie dafür eine Erklärung? Sagt sie, es gibt beide Trends. Man kann Flächenexpansionen genauso beobachten wie das Gegenteil. Die öffentliche Verwaltung reduziert eher Büroflächen. Nicht nur die Pandemie, auch die Immobilien und Energiepreise führen zum Flächenabbau an der TU Berlin, an der ich arbeite, steht pro Mitarbeiter unseres Forschungszentrums in Zukunft weniger Platz zur Verfügung. Also das heißt, wenige Wissenschaftler müssen sich dann ein Büro teilen. Und gern wird ja dann auch das so begründet, dass das doch unglaublich kommunikativ ist, wenn man da dicht beisammensetzt. Und das wird sie auch gefragt. Und da sagt sie, ne, das ist exakt das Gegenteil. Ich befürchte, die Kommunikation wird sich dadurch verschlechtern. Wenn Mitarbeiter im Homeoffice arbeiten, weil das Büro keine Konzentration ermöglicht oder schlecht ausgestattet ist, hat das nichts mit einer sinnvollen Flexibilisierung der Arbeitsumgebung zu tun. Im Gegenteil. Trotzdem haben wir es auch nach wie vor mit Prestigepauten zu tun. Zum Beispiel Google. Und zwar hat jetzt Google 900 Millionen Euro investiert in ein Bürokomplex in London. Und da sagt sie, ja, man braucht nicht zu glauben, wir machen alles digital und Homeoffice. Nein, Gebäude haben eine symbolische Bedeutung. Gebäude hat was mit Macht zu tun. Und später wird dann auch von Lautenbach noch Norbert Elias zitiert, der mal sagt, ein Herzog, der nicht herrschaftlich wie ein solcher wohnt, der ist schon fast keiner mehr. Und das gilt auch für die Konzerne. Und deswegen braucht man sich da gar nicht wundern, dass die nach wie vor groß bauen und zwar Homeoffice-Losungen anbieten, aber dass das keineswegs meint, dass der Komplex der Prestigeträchtige verschwindet. Was ich besonders interessant fand, war, wie wir eigentlich Räume und Städte und so etwas wahrnehmen. Und da sagt sie Folgendes. Wenn man in den 70er Jahren ein Kind aufgefordert hat, seinen Lebensraum zu zeichnen, waren das konzentrische Kreise. In der Mitte die Wohnung, im nächsten größeren Kreis die Straße, im dritten Kreis der Bezirk und der Ort. Heute zeichnen Kinder miteinander verbundene Inseln. Die Wohnung, die Schule, die Wohnung von Freunden und Verwandten, Freizeiteinrichtungen, Fußballplatz, Jugendmusikschule, den Ferienort. Das konzentrische Modell geht von einem einheitlichen, mich umgebenden Raum aus. Im Netzwerkmodell sind mehrere Orte lose miteinander verkoppelt. Und da fragt dann gleich der Interviewer nach, na ja, aber man hat sich doch früher auch von der Schule zum Fußballplatz oder so bewegt. Damals haben sie sich zu Fuß oder mit dem Fahrrad bewegt. Sie haben den sie umgebenden Raum ununterbrochen wahrgenommen. Heute werden Kinder auch zu weit entfernten Orten gefahren, zum Musikunterricht, Hockeytraining oder zur Sprachschule. Das trifft übrigens für Kinder auf dem Land noch stärker zu als für Kinder in der Stadt. Sie müssen von den Eltern oft über weite Distanzen transportiert werden und entwickeln kein Bild von den Zwischenräumen. Dazu kommen Flüge in Urlaubsgebiete, die Distanzen kaum erfahrbar machen. Insgesamt entsteht ein verinseltes Raumbild. Und da sagt sie, das sei etwas, was wir bei uns allen stark beobachten können. Und ich würde das auch für mich ganz klar sagen. Ich wohne ja in Koblenz und werde oft gefragt, ja, aber wie ist das so in Koblenz? Und ich denke so, ja, ich durchschreite ja Koblenz eher selten. Also es gibt punktuell Orte, zu denen ich hingehe, da gehe ich was essen, da kaufe ich mir eine Zeitung. Aber ich durchschreite Koblenz nicht so, wie das vielleicht vor 30, 40 Jahren ein Koblenzer getan hat, sondern wenn ich eine Nähe zu Menschen aufsuche, ist das nicht, ich gehe 500 Meter, sondern das bedeutet auch oft, ich fahre irgendwo 45 Minuten hin. Oder ich komme zu dir nach Frankfurt, wir machen einen Podcast. Oder ich fahre nach Köln in die Philharmonie. Und das sind Inseln. Und klar, ich fahre da über eine Autobahn hin und ich kann mich nicht beamen. Aber ich nehme nicht die Autobahn als Teil dieses gesamten konzentrischen Kreises wahr. Sondern ich bewege mich von Insel zu Insel. Und denke mir manchmal, schade, dass ich mich nicht beamen kann.
Ja, also ich denke da auch gerade viel drüber nach, weil sich Frankfurt am Main anbietet, als eine Stadt wahrgenommen zu werden. Das ist nicht eine Metropole wie Berlin oder so, wo man echt Hilfe braucht, um von der einen Terminlage zur nächsten zu kommen und dazwischen die irgendwie zwei Stunden Nahverkehr und sowas. Hier in Frankfurt lässt sich alles zu Fuß erreichen, außer in der Peripherie die richtigen Wohnstädte, die es halt dann so gibt. Aber so dieses Zentrum Frankfurt, wenn man sich so anschaut, was wird hier abgefahren von der Stadtrundfahrt oder so. Das lässt sich erlaufen ergehen. Da kann man wirklich auch gemütlich die Stadt erkunden und so ein gesamtheitliches Bild, Mikrokosmos gewinnen. Was ich jetzt auch wieder mehr nutzen will. Wie gesagt, Corona ist vorbei und so weiter. Für die Kinder finde ich das auch. Das ist mir auch wieder aufgefallen. Die sind ja am Anfang so klein. Du sagst denen ja nicht, was du vorhast, sondern du bist halt zu Hause, fütterst die irgendwie, dann packst du die ein und eine halbe Stunde später sind die im Schwimmbad. Die wissen ja gar nicht, wie es ihnen geschieht. Dann sind die da eine Weile, dann sind sie wieder woanders. Irgendwann kommt dieser Moment, wo man die Kinder mitnimmt, auch geistig, wo man sie vorbereitet, Vorfreude in der Rolle spielt, Nachbetrachtung, was hat dir heute am besten gefallen. Das stimmt, diese Beobachtung ist immer so abgenudelt. Früher haben die Kinder das alles selbst entdeckt. Heute ist es nur noch so punktuell. Aber da gibt es auf jeden Fall einen gewissen Handlungsbedarf. Die Zahlen des 30 Milliarden Euro. Hier in Frankfurt wurde die Tage ein einzelnes Gebäude für mehr als 1 Milliarde Euro der teuerste Deal, der jemals stattfand, was Immobilien angeht in Deutschland. Es ist eine krasse Dimension dafür, dass gerade alles ein bisschen im Abriss ist. Aber irgendwo ist da immer noch Geld da. Und diese Häuser sind noch nie mal gebaut. Zurück in den Krieg. Die Washington Post hat einen Text, den stelle ich euch jetzt in dem Sinne vor, dass ich sage, wer das lesen will, kann es selber lesen. Aber ich fand es dann doch auch so ein bisschen... Na, wie soll ich sagen? Manchmal hat man so Biografien vor sich. Die sind einfach echt. Und die nehmen einen so ein bisschen mit. Also bis zum letzten Sommer war Khalid Payenda afghanischer Finanzminister mit Hoheit über 6 Milliarden Dollar Budget. Und jetzt, sieben Monate später, Kabul ist gefallen, die Taliban haben die Macht übernommen, er sitzt in einem Honda-Akkord und ist Uber-Triver in Washington. Es gehört also zu seinem Beruf, die ganze Zeit Leute hin und her zu fahren, die ihn nicht kennen, selber dann hier an der Weltbank, am Internationalen Währungsforum und so weiter vorbei, zu wissen, wie es da drin nicht zugeht, dort Seminare gegeben genommen und wie auch immer gehalten zu haben. Und jetzt sitzt er halt unten und wartet auf Fahrer. Mit diesem ersten Zitat von ihm, wenn ich 50 Trips in den nächsten zwei Tagen schaffe, kriege ich einen 95-Dollar-Bonus. Und das ist natürlich wirklich traurig. Er hat eine Frau, er hat vier Kinder, er ist selber 40 Jahre alt. Sie sind geflüchtet eine Woche, bevor das da alles zerbrach, weil er auch gefeuert wurde. Ghani war irgendwie sauer. Da gab es irgendwie so eine kleine Zahlung an den Libanon oder so. Die hat nicht geklappt. Und dann stand da irgendwie so auch politischer Verrat. Also die Nerven lagen einfach blank.
Das heißt, er war dann jemand, der nicht korrupt war. Denn da sind ja auch einige mit den großen Taschen Bargeld ausgeflogen von der Führungselite Afghanistan.
Ja, das ist jetzt nur ein Text, der so einfach drauf schaut, mit ihm spricht, viele Zitate. Aber diese Art der Korruption, und woran hat es eigentlich gemangelt? In Afghanistan quält ihn. Denn er lebt jetzt in Washington und weiß, meine eigentliche Heimat gibt es so nicht. Zu der komme ich nicht zurück. Er ist auch als Kind schon mal geflüchtet. Also er ist jetzt 40. Der ist schon mal vor den Taliban oder wer auch immer damals, Mujahideen oder wie auch immer. Wir kennen ja die Geschichte so ein bisschen. Schon mal geflüchtet, jetzt wieder geflüchtet. Afghanistan liegt wieder in Trümmern. Er weiß, wie es da zugeht und er leidet. Er fährt sozusagen heimatlos in Washington, durch Virginia, also wirklich Washington DC fährt er jetzt Taxi und weiß nicht ein noch aus und erinnert sich dann eben auch so insgesamt, wie das war. Er war schon hier und sieht im Fernsehen, was vor sich geht und kriegt dann eben eine Nachricht des ehemaligen World Bank Directors, der für sein Kabul zuständig war. Der schreibt ihm einfach, what a sad day, weil keiner mehr Worte findet. Also alle sind dieser Nachrichtenlage total ausgeliefert. Wir wissen ja, wie die Amerikaner da vor Ort nur noch versucht haben, so von jetzt auf gleich irgendwie das zu regeln und genau so standen eben alle Beteiligten. Und dann sind das halt so wirklich krasse Szenen. Einfach, wenn man sich das so vorstellt. Er ist Uber-Driver hier, alle, manche konnten so noch flüchten, einige noch in Afghanistan. Aber diese alten Eliten, also die zu seiner Zeit mit ihm versucht haben, da Afghanistan aufzubauen, haben einfach nur noch so eine WhatsApp-Gruppe, alle verstreut auf der Welt und kommentieren sich so gegenseitig das, was sie im Fernsehen sehen. Also das ist so das Sense-Making auf der Ebene, finde das da irgendwie statt. Das ist schon ziemlich düster. Der Text ist sehr lang, geht da sehr ins Detail drauf ein. Auch in Anpracht der Zeit springe ich mal zu dieser Pointe. Wir haben das letzte Mal auch darüber gesprochen, was sind eigentlich First-World-Problems, was sind sozusagen echte Probleme? Kann man irgendwie das Leid der einen, das Leid der anderen, wir haben dann auch verglichen bei der Ukraine, sind nicht gerade viele in Deutschland erpicht darauf, wieder eine Sozialität zu erleben, nicht einsam zu sein, Mann zu sein und dann aber halt im Krieg. Und sind nicht sehr viele im Krieg, die lieber eine Einsamkeit in der totalen Heimatlosigkeit hier in Kauf nehmen. Hauptsache erst mal raus aus körperlicher Gefahr und so. Dass es da so eine gewisse Gemengelage gibt. Und er fährt eben dieses Taxi, hat lauter Leuten zu tun, die ihn nicht kennen. Es ist aber dieses Washington, wo eben sehr viele superreiche Leute, Dunstkreis, Hauptstadt und amerikanisches Machtzentrum und so weiter. Und er sieht halt lauter Leute auf seinem Rücksitz, die leiden. Die total berauscht, aber eben nicht durch Glückseligkeit, weil sie in einer freien Welt leben, sondern weil sie einfach... Geil, ich habe fünf Tage gearbeitet, jetzt habe ich mir erst mal verdient, mir so richtig die Birne wegzuhacken. Und dann sitzen sie halt zwei Uhr nachts bei ihm im Auto. Das ist für ihn die lukrativste Zeit zu fahren. Kriegt dann immer gleich so einen 19-Dollar-Bonus irgendwie. Er macht dann pro Nacht irgendwie 150 Dollar. Natürlich muss er alles selber bezahlen. Sein Auto, den Sprit und so, der ganze Kram. Also es lohnt sich eigentlich kaum. Im Grunde ist es so, er hat ein Elend gegen das andere eingetauscht. Nur diesmal ist es nicht so lebensbedrohlich. Aber das sind keine glücklichen Leute, die da irgendwie von Party zu Party fährt oder so. Sondern für ihn ist einfach die ganze Welt kaputt. Und das ist wirklich traurig. Aber es ist einfach ein sehr guter Text, bei dem auch noch mal viel, ja, es ist einfach eine richtig schöne Begleitung von ihm, die er auch verdient hat, finde ich so. Diese Art der Aufmerksamkeit, dass man hier noch mal so ihn einlädt, auch darüber zu reden. Er hatte zwischendurch irgendwelche Jobs, wo er dann noch mal 2000 Dollar pro Semester an irgendwelchen Unis verdient hat, um zu erklären, wie das so ist als Finanzminister. Aber sowas zahlt sich dann auch wirklich nicht aus in Amerika. Also er muss jetzt so richtig von unten anfangen. Und naja, Corona-Episode. Seine Eltern sind dann noch gestorben in Afghanistan, weil er es als Finanzminister nicht hingebrauchen hat, irgendwie Hilfe aufzutreiben für seine eigenen Eltern. Dann ist seine Mutter da vor ihm gestorben und so. Na ja, einfach eine richtig traurige Geschichte.
Aber selten, dass du uns mal eine Reportage empfiehlst. Das ist doch eine, oder? Na ja, nicht so mit, ich reise jetzt alleine nach Afghanistan und beschreibe euch die Atmosphäre, aber schon.
Genau, es ist nicht so die situativ-szänische, sondern es ist der ganz große Weltenbogen einmal runtergebrochen auf so eine Biografie. Also das kann ich einfach zum Lesen auch so empfehlen.
Ich habe noch einen Artikel aus der FAZ zum Herrenanzug. Und dieser Artikel ist übertitelt mit Goodbye Herrenanzug. Was ist da los? Ich mache es ja immer häufiger aus, wenn ich so durch die Straßen gehe. Wo ist er eigentlich geblieben, der Herrenanzug? Jetzt haben wir klare Fakten, die bestätigen, was ich sehe. Ja, der Herrenanzug ist auf dem Rückzug. Seit Corona vor zwei Jahren 100.000 Cityherren aus den Büros vertrieben hat, kaufen die britischen Banker, Anwälte, Berater und Beamten immer weniger Dreiteiler und Anzüge. Das hat nun das hier zur Folge. Das britische Statistikamt ONS hat den formellen Anzug nun sogar aus seinem Warenkorb entfernt, mit dem ist die Inflationsrate berechnet. Mehr als 700 Güter sind in dem Warenkorb vertreten. Der Herrenanzug, 1947 in die Statistik aufgenommen, fliegt nun raus, er sei nicht mehr so relevant. Wir wissen ja, um die Inflation zu berechnen, muss man so einen Warenkorb zusammenstellen. Es gibt ja auch dann Debatten darüber, was kommt da rein? Warum machen das die Schweizer anders als die Deutschen? Ist es vielleicht viel genauer, das so wie die Schweizer zu machen? Und jetzt hat man sich also entschieden, dass man diesen Herrenanzug im Warenkorb nicht mehr braucht. Eine Schätzung der Marktforscher von Canter ergab, dass im Jahr 2020 die Verkaufszahlen für Anzüge auf der Insel von 5 auf 2 Millionen gefallen ist. Mark Spencer hat entschieden, in der Hälfte seiner Bekleidungsgeschäfte keine Anzüge mehr anzubieten. Man sieht auch deutlich weniger Krawattenträger in der Londoner City. Nun, das ist die Entwicklung, und die zeigt sich dann im Warenkorb. Im Übrigen, im Warenkorb ist neu dafür zum Beispiel der Sport-BH. Das ist jetzt bei Blazer natürlich auch. Weniger eine Rolle spielen überhaupt. Casual-Mode, Smart-Casual, wie es heißt, ist überall stark vertreten. Man kann es auch ein bisschen daran sehen, dass Boss einen neuen CEO hat, der auch Wert darauf legt, dass man jetzt Anzüge macht, die man in die Waschmaschine stopfen kann und so.
Das wäre für mich sofort ein Kaufabend.
Nein, nein, nein, das ist das. Also das kann ganz gut sein, wenn das funktioniert. Die Tendenz ist ganz klar, dass der Anzug und der Jogging-Anzug sich stark angleichen. Aber dann ist es kein Anzug mehr in meinen Augen. Und wie sieht es in Deutschland aus? Da heißt es, der Herneanzug hat keine große Verbrauchsbedeutung. Teilt auch das Statistische Bundesamt mit. Mit gerade einmal 0,73 Promille wird er im Statistischen Warenkorb gewichtet. Das heißt, gibt ein Deutscher 1.000 Euro aus, fließen davon durchschnittlich 73 Cent in die Anschaffung von Herneanzügen. Also ich glaube, wir müssen da gegenkämpfen. Der Anzug muss zurück.
Ich habe mich ja schon weiter erklärt.
Genau, du hast es mir ja schon beim Schnitzel gesagt. Du überlegst doch, dir einen Anzug anzuschaffen. Und ich soll dir dabei behilflich sein. Nichts lieber als das, das werden wir in den kommenden Wochen irgendwann mal in Frankfurt machen. Und ich kann dich da sehr unterstützen. Du wirst uns dann erzählen, wie dein Tragegefühl ist. Vielleicht sagst du ja auch, ich war ein Verörter all die Jahre. Und ab sofort trage ich nur noch Anzug. Ich bin gespannt, wie es sein wird. Vielleicht lesen wir dann bald, dass er für die Inflation wieder sehr relevant wird, der Anzug.
Ganz genau. Also ich habe mir schon ein Budget zurechtgelegt. Zeit wird noch organisiert. Und dann gehen wir hier mir einen Anzug machen lassen, wie man es früher häufig tat. Und ich werde den Trend jetzt wieder begründen. Oder ihm zumindest noch mal nacheilen, wo er uns entflieht. Das ist natürlich auch schade, denn ich sehe es ja natürlich auch gerne. Aber es gibt diesen Spruch von Wolfgang Joop, der Jugend steht das weiße T-Shirt am liebsten. Und irgendwie hänge ich immer noch nach, dass ich nicht so alt bin, wie ich bin. Nun gut, damit haben wir den ganzen Salon abgenudelt, oder?
Genau, wir würden vielleicht noch darauf hinweisen, was wir vorhaben, nächstes Mal zu lesen. Und zwar hatten wir gedacht, wir lesen mal was über Luxus. Es erscheint ein Buch, das heißt Die Zukunft des Luxus von Erwin Rambour, der in der Luxusbranche lange tätig war. Wir sind gespannt, was er über die Zukunft des Luxus berichten kann, wie sich das auch in einer globalen Welt verhalten wird. Ein auf jeden Fall sehr wichtiges Thema, glaube ich. Wenngleich die Luxuskonzerne momentan ein bisschen zu schwächeln scheinen. Denn die Sanktionen wirken offenbar auch da. Man kann nicht mehr so viel nach Russland importieren. Und auch die Lust auf Luxus ist vielleicht gerade in Kriegszeiten nicht besonders hoch. Denn wenn man mal schaut, bei Caring oder LVMH sind die Aktien ziemlich eingebrochen. Offenbar hat diese Kriegsstimmung auch die Stimmung für den Luxus verdorben.
Die sollen sich mal nicht so haben. Also wenn einer weiß, wo Marktlücken ausgebeutet werden können, sind die ja wohl diejenigen, die es am ehesten finden oder selber graben. Und dann uns Marktlücken präsentieren, in die wir dann natürlich alle gerne reinspringen. Sofern das Geld zur Verfügung steht. Sehr gut, dann verabschieden wir uns hier und sagen, habt alle einen tollen April. Der macht natürlich, was er will. Hier weht es schon wieder und regnet. Mal gucken, wir wünschen allen nur das Beste. Bis dann.